you
what up everybody Welcome to the H3
podcast March 1st
the dawn of a new month
we are here we are ready we are coming
in waves
God I woke up this morning and like
first thing I set up I had like a cramp
in my neck or something
oh I can't really move my head in full
motion okay all right
I was talking about something important
have a good night
have a good night yeah one of my
favorite Knives have a good night yeah
one of my favorite nights wait wait let
me talk 16 is the age of consent team
star shut up
[Music]
awesome
I love that a little special keemstar uh
medley
it's nice to remind everybody from time
to time just what a piece of [__] he is
thank you
goddamn those so back to the important
stuff my neck
oh I guess I don't am I not eating
enough bananas is that what cramps are
so they say right potassium I
believe okay what's going on it's so
it's so windy I just came inside it
wasn't windy at all and it sounds like
our building's about to collapse yeah I
think it's the tarp up there being
caught in the wind would that makes
sense but I'm hearing it like all over
the place
like it's just Wendy's free so more than
one target up there brick dude
because we were yeah we were leaking we
were bad baby but anyway we'll figure it
out here we are guys
today's episode sponsored by
teddyfresh.com
anal leaking
uh we don't have a sponsor today so
thank you to Teddy fresh AKA my
beautiful wife Ela
why is it so windy I don't know if you
guys can hear it
but it it sounds apocalyptic
like legit I've never
yeah when I went downstairs door was
like swinging from Dan says it's
hurricane force winds outside I mean
we've
foreign
where did this come from
it's been like this though the past few
days you guys have been it's been
freezing and windy yes I've been
complaining every morning I come in I
say oh my God it's so cold it's been
cold but aren't you from Detroit Lina
you've been spoiled so yeah I don't know
what's going on with her every morning
she comes in and complains for like five
minutes about the weather it is cool it
has been incredibly or remarkably uh out
of ordinary cold here but
I just know you were here all morning do
you didn't hear that kind of
no okay all right well
the good news is we got lots of rain
here in California
but
didn't we need oh have you seen that
Meme we need it we did need we needed it
though we sure did
anyway teddyfresh.com check it out
there's all kinds of nice stuff going on
here guys
check it out it's awesome stuff this one
this one's still available it's the
colorful rib fuzzy v-neck sweater
oh it's just one size
thank you
one size oh wow one size that that
doesn't give a lot of info
I don't I've never seen us do that
before wow
we'll take a rip take a gamble on our
colorful rib fuzzy v-neck sweater and
pray that it fits
yes sir
oh this is a beautiful piece I gotta
wear one of these because it's just so
so beautiful I mean come on
dress like your Persian Grandma's couch
and if you really love the sweater you
can cover it
that is very very true and
if you really love it you can cover it
in plastic yep wow
but it is absolutely gorgeous that was a
[__] curveball
I just got to speak the facts it's
beautiful
uh so there it is teddyfresh.com take a
look check it out thank you thank you to
Chrissy Sherlock for gifting 20. love
that so nice actually yeah we had a
really nice episode yesterday of um
see you next Tuesday Ela joined me
and we had some really wholesome fun
moments there I should say at the top we
have a freaking awesome show planned
today
the concept is Ethan's Extreme Makeover
each one of these guys went to a
different thrift store
and spent about 25 each
on a new look some people went over 25
and we're gonna have to deduct for that
some came in under budget some people
came under by significantly under but
Olivia for example you spent 47 dollars
did you get some of us were blinded by
beautiful shoes that are gonna make your
outfit you spent twenty dollars on shoes
it was ridiculous but it was an
incredible deal and I forgot that we
were trying to spend as little as
possible I told Dan originally because I
know thrift store prices ain't what they
used to be I told Dan fifty dollars
makes more sense to me just wait till
you see the shoes but you guys all were
under 50. so
that's pretty exciting so each one of
you put together a whole outfit for me
I'm gonna be uh changing into each one
and then we'll be doing a poll to see
who is the ultimate
uh well not queer eye because but what
do we call it here straight eye we also
straight I don't know
just a bunch of people buy outfits for
Ethan I good eye the ultimate eye the
good eye club today I feel uh gay
without assuming sexual orientation I
club right today I feel uh gay wow how
about that how about the pride minute
eye Club
um I got my eye on you Chrissy Sherlock
gave another other will she give another
one 40. no I added them together oh
thank you so much Chrissy Chrissy
so that's super exciting that is gonna
be a ton of fun
I guess it's the thrift store makeover
apparently we have another uh queer eye
segment coming up
which is queer minute I I think we can
settle on that
we may not be queer but we are queer for
a minute during this segment I anybody
thank you try my best over here
yeah so we had actually a really fun
time on see you next Tuesday
there were some funny moments actually
on the subreddit I want to pull up one
of ela just
absolutely
I'm not commenting on this I'm just
playing it for posterity I want you guys
to see it
why is everyone spamming fake Zach
I don't know what that means
I don't know what you're talking about I
don't either what is she talking about
so slick so as you guys can see why did
she get so confused by that I missed I
think she forgot
[Music]
yeah but uh so there you have it we
don't know nothing about no fake Zach
I don't know nothing about we don't need
nothing about nobody well I don't
understand what this fake Zach thing
came from I don't know spamming in the
chat the other day became like a meme
like y'all are chat [__] trip like
what it's me it's me I mean I heard your
voice I saw you right I don't know this
came out of nowhere
yeah also don't worry guys I'm not
disappearing for an hour today I'll be
here for the whole show
that's my guarantee to you today
I also discussed uh yesterday that
um
Eddie will be coming back on Monday
to do a don't worry he's not going to be
doing another hour monologue he's just
gonna be here to support me morally and
I want to give him another opportunity
to shine he was not if as if he wasn't
shining enough I mean that was the
audition he's shown in a way yeah yeah
he'll just be sidekicking me on on um on
Monday already in Eddie head love it I
just wanted out there and Ed head yeah
more than an Ethernet
also not to talk about somebody's
body disparagingly but
this this was on the summer I just saw
this
marjor and Taylor gross
yeah she's got some
some Talons man
she's a [__] lizard they don't talk
about lizard people and all this [__]
she got dinosaur feet yeah I was gonna
say they're more bird-like yeah you have
three
you're a demon she's a demon she's not
even human and this proves it she is so
she is so vile I thought it was just
something about the shoes but um
wait it's fake no
I haven't seen an article right here
maybe it's not fake I saw other pictures
it says three toe feet go viral and
doctorate photo you find me the real one
AB because I actually fact checked this
on my own because I said this is too
good to be true this she's got it
walking around like a Talon the goddamn
chicken head
but then I saw another one of her on the
beach and sure enough yeah exactly yeah
here
yeah look at that well so this one's
more confusing because that one I'm this
one has four that one has four
one two no it's got five it's just these
two on the side are like squeezed
together at the very
at the very least it seems like her toes
are very separated are these two curled
up or something okay I think it's curl
because I've seen it like that in old
people they're just bunched up or like
they overlap that's what I thought is
that a sign of some kind of like
condition
when your middle toes Bunch up to make
one super toe
I hate to uh go ahead AB just my job let
me send it I've got the original extend
it near I want to know I just I'm here
for the truth
I seen this uh circulating and I just
want to know the truth here
oh boy oh boy we're just here
everyone's speculating after the beach
photos a while back that she has three
toes have been proven wrong she
definitely has at least four toes
here she is of course with known Q Anon
conspiracy theorists uh
what's his name Flynn yeah Flint
okay so this is the real photo
because here what's here there's four
there's only four does here
we've still got a problem
the count is off is the could the pinky
be under this but look the count is off
stop the count
Marjorie the machines they're they're
flipping toes speed picks so on the
right one you can you can see five toes
there's five yeah but she's got some
[__] up toes man where's the fifth toe
where's the final toe where are the
votes where are the toes we demand
Christy Sherlock is a ultimate fupa
Trooper thank you so much Chrissy I love
you for that okay well marjorie's on
Wiki feet so this is kind of
oh my God I was watching um
again yesterday on the members podcast
we were watching this um True Crime
Channel J C S yeah which is super great
but we were watching the one about what
it looks like to fake a
a it's fake that your insanity
it's the guy who did the Parkland
shooting Nicholas and he was footless at
one point and we're like yeah you gotta
you know he's on wikiFeet and actually I
never looked it up but people said they
did what was his name
or I hate to say his name
just type it to me I need to know if
he's up on wikiFeet or not
I mean Charles Manson is right we
confirmed that
maybe you you just type it in and tell
me if it is or not yeah
okay let's see here
we beat men Amy do me a favor put
together an album of her toes and we can
get a comprehensive look
uh of what we can see because I can't
really zoom in
okay okay yeah make an album for me and
we'll do a full report here for for
later for office and for now and later
now and later oh boy oh boy
[Music]
[Laughter]
anyway uh so that was on the subject uh
they do not appear to have a wikiFeet
page okay okay yeah sorry
I disappoint okay well I was just
curious how thorough they were that's
all right yeah sorry Jerry
sorry anyway that was it there was a few
other Clips but I'm not seeing them but
yeah we had fun and thank you guys so
much there's a clip go look for the clip
I know I'm trying Kimmy
now there is this one clip but uh anyway
so that was fun
hey where was this clip from Dan
which
is this must be from a members yeah BTS
yeah POV you're a bag of salt and
vinegar chips
okay sure wow that's powerful you can
see that wow
God damn I ow
e Alfredo you okay Alfredo keeps jumping
at me I think he's scared
Alfredo it's okay baby alfredo we found
some new Wendy Williams juice I mean
this is a long time it's interesting
that after all this time there's still
nuggets on Earth yeah I couldn't believe
you guys hadn't seen this before
oh my God this is this is wonderful do
we have any windy updates she's making a
podcast did that ever come in a podcast
is that out yet because she just needs a
mic Williams podcast
the Wendy Experience Podcast Instagram
page seems like a good place to start
now the move would be Monday foreign
Zach what were you saying you got
brutally uh yeah thank you Dan for
talking over me yeah um
I was told to investigate this okay the
move would be having Eddie on it must
suck to be cut off Zach huh yeah it's a
real bummer what did Zach do to deserve
this is he has he wronged you guys in
some way I mean he stepped in front of
me in the photo
there is there is bad will back there
for you there's no ill will
anyways
go ahead I'm just waiting for someone to
talk over me come on don't do it okay
okay okay Monday anyway so let's move on
to the next story this is taking too
long you want to talk about Wendy
Williams podcast sorry Zach I couldn't
resist it's their fault
so is it out or no
uh does not appear to be it looks like
they're all ready to launch though how
you doing merch that's what I'm saying
they already have podcast merch in this
I need to how you doing uh hoodie
I don't want a hoodie that's too much of
an investment wait zoom in that is that
is not a real hoodie that is just a
graphic that they put on top of the
hoodie for like that's not a real hoodie
yeah it's very just a second the strings
are going behind holy [__] dude how you
how are you doing Wendy
Zach what were you gonna say I'm very
sorry I won't you can beautiful I prefer
not this one you're gonna say Mondays
for Eddie I shouldn't speak I prefer not
to speak I'm done
point is moot
bro he interrupted me I'm trying to help
you out here I was trying to say that
Wednesday I think he was going to say
Wednesdays are for Wendy Wendy's are for
Wendy that's it see that was a really
important point to get out there yeah
super important yeah thank you for
belittling yes I got you bro all right
here's Wendy Wednesdays are for Wendy
or she's like Wendy you got him they're
long you show them
you show how you do it that's what I
need how you doing you can't see my
mouth but you can see the words coming
out of my mouth how you doing
how you doing storm that's about to
[__] who's outside the Big Bad Wolf
well our studio is made of brick so we
should be fine even
by that fabled story
she also talked me into picking out this
outfit today
she's also died
this is about her mother she she is the
greatest at announcing death she is so
good at delivering bad news So Graceful
we gotta actually yeah there's gotta be
like this is the fifth they died
like we need a compilation of
of Wendy just she's also died
she's the best that ever did it oh poor
Alfredo he's scared oh [__] damn
Shredder I just run what is wrong with
you guys
you guys scared
y outside camera Shredder you want to
come up too
here we go
all right we're just doing the show like
this today hi guys
[Music]
it's so scary out there oh Shredder you
want to come up on the table check stuff
out
[Music]
okay Shred
oh I got you I got you
a little update on
uh Wendy's podcast here
on the website it has like a about and
when I click to read more
we get this
okay so they're close to the lawn
Wendy is pretty wealthy I'm surprised
she doesn't like put a little more
resources into this she's also died
she may be she may not have much time
left to be totally honest should she
stop you know that I'm gonna be like she
she once told me to just be myself she's
inspired me my whole life she's also
died
when she dies yeah oh true I'm planning
that's like to that's that's honoring
her though yeah I'm planning her
obituary already I will announce it on
the show so Wendy Williams greatest ever
do it if you're out there we still want
you I would co-host a show with you any
day oh now we're talking but my point
originally was Eddie Monday we should
try and get Wendy on every Wednesday
Wendy Wednesdays
I would pay her a lot of money for Wendy
Wednesday
not that she needs it she's super rich I
think
but you know it's motivating
oh we got MGD toes album
all right so so Amy you went to with her
Wiki feet page and put together
these are all real receipts
I mean I can't tell because they have
both that photo and the three webbed uh
uh I'll be saying the fake or the the
altered one was on Wiki feed so maybe
this isn't the most well once again this
the left foot we know has five toes
right the right foot
see now the
Saturday
oh my God
oh [__] let's see I'm con I'm worried
about the right foot it's never oh
you're so right where wait you gotta
find some of the right foot AB I think I
don't know if it exists I hope it's good
wherever it is
oh I need that right toe shot it's so
weird it's like every right
every photo of her right foot is turned
or hidden somehow because she knows
something I need that far right toe
before I can bust
that's what the Wikipedia they're like
that's my favorite toe
um
oh is she spotted in the wild have you
ever asked c-man if he had a like a one
toe is more irrelevant I never did ask
him that yeah
I don't know if like the big toe versus
like the tiny toe the pinky toe I like
them all you know they're all pretty
good they all have their own mirror I
think I know what he did yeah I like
that it's more about the whole foot you
know but I like it I like them all
they're right I guess I don't know so
here is Wendy who has spotted um
somewhere
I'm going
somebody help it oh [__] just I tried to
help her but she had a nasty attitude
like WTF windy I hope you feeling better
and then it's in Spanish from there
he is the best
Queen
I'm going
somebody help it
I hope
no
dude she's awesome that was the best
would you like some help uh no
[Applause]
that's so funny dude she is the greatest
that ever did it period
the top comment is you got the real
Wendy Williams experience
so true
it's okay it's okay although this guy
has a fair point you need help with the
phone in her face right that's true
that's true it's not the most graceful
way to ask somebody if they need help
General plea to the public somebody to
help me
I don't see anybody else there
there's other videos where she just
screams out someone helped me what
the whole world is her servitude to her
she she just expects anyone to grab her
no
oh my she is so awesome man we miss you
at the bottom of her website you can
actually apply to be a guest on the
podcast let's apply put me in the ringer
I'll put me yeah yeah okay I'll sign up
right now
sadly I might be the most famous person
with me today
for my first guest her audience would
have no idea who I was it would be so
special that would be so awesome I'm a
pretty big dealer though where I come
from Wendy
love says don't put your real phone
number because that's probably not a
secure website yeah that's right yeah
they're definitely not secure
um
here's another fun little bit at the top
here for you guys to enjoy
a little bit of a blooper if you will
okay you should be coming down any
minute now
this [__] got me laughing so hard dude
you're uh uh
how do you even deal with that as like
an employee
sadly like we always laugh about this in
my family my mom always has this saying
throughout our whole life she goes you
can drown in a teaspoon of water
and then we well have I talked about
this
you how do you drown in a teaspoon of
water she goes oh you could choke on it
that's not drowning
how do you drown in a teaspoon of water
I know that in a babysitting course it
said something like a kids can drown in
two inches of water two inches of like a
body what about like a teaspoon that's a
lot more than a teaspoon I assume
but wouldn't the water just
go down your throat that's what I assume
I just always found that thing so CBS
2's Maurice Dubois reported Sports
Medicine specialist Dr Louis maharam
says it's a condition known as Drive the
big news
I don't think anyone knows what that's
even from we showed it on the show I
know I know but it's a deep it's a deep
one well it takes uh just a few
teaspoons of water to go down the wrong
way and into the lungs we'll drown you
you it's called dry drowning oh yeah but
okay but you have happened all the time
to children playing around the pool or
the lake no you need to stop spreading
this information right now the top
results on Google which is never wrong
says that you can it you know they say a
few teaspoons of water okay so your
mom's still what I don't know book is
dry drowning like tell me what is that
oh just water goes into your room and
you die like what the [__] kind of
bodies are we walking around in or a
couple of teaspoons of water kills you
sparkling water like that doesn't make
any sense to me Checkmate [__]
Christians how you gonna talk about
intelligent design when we there's
people walking around dying from two
teaspoons of water
or I mean not just Christians the whole
Theocratic institution just got
checkmated
yeah no just religion in general well
anyway my point was I guess she was in a
right kind of she was kind of right in a
way because look at this guy fighting
for his life and like three inches of
water
good what the [__]
[Music]
hahaha
the the recorder just bails I wonder she
says Idiot I think it's uh the wife
there must have been something that went
on that day this [__] idiot
he's Fed Up
I feel bad man but you got to work on
your water skills
it's like he's putting his head back as
much as possible to drown himself
oh that's a good one that's that's
powerful I love that thank you thank you
for sharing that love that
mm-hmm
this is horrible news breaking news oh
boy
this okay this is a big problem the
United States House foreign Affair
committee voted on Wednesday today this
morning along party lines to give
President Joe Biden about great news no
it's not great no it's not Dan
is our home
now you ban Tick Tock then you're gonna
see some real protests you're going to
see young people mobilize for the first
time in this country's history
they voted along party lines
cowards to give President Joe Biden the
power to ban Chinese Zone tick tock
and what would be the most far-reaching
U.S restriction of any social media app
now this is a [__] travesty because
we cannot let Ryan Kavanaugh win because
the minute this [__] gets banned triller
people are gonna go start using triller
and that's just not open nobody's
[__] with triller yeah no it happened
last time when there was all this
hysteria they even yeah but that was
before all of all the [__]
listen to puffy oral friend I never seem
so scared
what's the problem with Tick Tock why
are they so upset by it they always want
to ban it it's so upsetting every I feel
like every time I Tick Tock is growing
this said this happens again it stopped
you actually want to know
yeah sure I'd love to I mean it's
[__] by the way because they they
are accusing it of uh being uh spyware
essentially
everything spyware uh like what's so
special about Tick Tock that China's
getting this Tick Tock is our home from
every from things that I've read that
Tick Tock is very invasive like the
amount of data collected is absurd these
people are all logged in on Facebook
that's what I'm saying even compared to
Facebook it's it's particularly bad but
people say that about everything I
posted a tick tock about that ring cam
we got for my car and people are like oh
great now you're letting police spy on
you 24 7. 100 what do you think about
everything well I mean that that's also
true who are we taking this very
personally who are we as a country to
say oh we're just gonna ban all China
what's the whole Chinese social media
app like I agree we should ban them all
that's what's next like yep who are we
we got to decide who we are as a country
are we just gonna ban like are we not
gonna be to work with Chinese companies
at all like where's the risk stop I'm
sure that we have a lot of collaboration
and collaboration is what keeps the
world together you want another age of
isolation where we ban Tick Tock and the
China retaliates and then all of a
sudden we're both separated and isolated
that's how war begins that's how
that's how aggression starts yeah this
is right this is where we've been
getting along with China so well the
last couple decades anyways you get a
longing which we're still incredible
trade Partners Dan despite the saber
rattling that takes place in the public
yes the reality is that we are
codependent we are symbiotic we are
friends and we should stand with the
Chinese people
when it comes jerking off
yeah and I I stand out I stand with the
Chinese government
you're right we should not be based tick
dog Pace China
Ethan the maoist let's go
I just I we cannot let Ryan Kavanaugh
win we need to let their culture into
our country we need to have a revolution
we need to have one would say like some
sort of cultural revolution here in the
United States whatever it takes to keep
running whatever it takes that's right I
agree let me read you something in June
2020 Tick Tock had more than 200 million
Indian users and then as soon as it got
banned they went straight to triller 200
million
for the Thriller number one yep I it
doesn't matter what is the full world
aware of the triller controversy like I
do you think they're going to do their
research before downloading that app
she's right she's 100 right wait they're
really super popular in India how many
users they have an interview they were
not good they're number one I believe
let me see the number one social media
app it was at one point this is not a
good situation we have to stop this we
have to stop Miss Leto we need to March
this is causing this is causing a riff
this is causing a rift here what did
President XI ever do to you make change
up uplift the people of China do you
know he's a limited road projects Belton
roads you know he's eliminated poverty
people are living a hot a middle-class
life before they were eating
unbelievable grubs out of the earth
highest populated country on the planet
lifted out of poverty in record time
unbelievable I'm based I don't know if
it's still number one but it did jump to
number one as soon as it was blocked
that summer okay this is August 2020 bro
they were they were popping at that time
everywhere yeah I need to know why
hasn't India banned trailer if they're
like you want America's spying on you
India did no trailer oh trailer like
what you're okay with India spying on
you
bro it literally says his name right
here owned by Hollywood producer Ryan
Kavanaugh this is not okay
I'm not worried about triller
that's all I'm saying you think if tick
tock goes down triller won't take no
what we're they're out it sucks this
shit's flipped dude well you're you kind
of have a point I wonder if YouTube and
Instagram have positioned themselves
exactly I would say Instagram is the
best position because they've basically
copied tick tock's whole app at this
point it is Tick Tock but not sports but
not their growth algorithm which was the
main attraction to Tick-Tock there is
it's not even true Instagram's not the
same it's like the whole ecosystem this
way to meet girls well right because
Tick Tock exists and they they are still
distinguishing themselves I'm just
saying they are better positioned than
triller to take all the influx of people
leaving I just I'm not okay with this
you know what I mean like he's just he's
the fattest walking L I cannot handle
him taking a win here
I'm converting I'll become a communist
I'll do whatever the [__] it takes right
please excellent
um I should point out
the likelihood oh yeah that's great two
hairline Kings that's right cam look at
this look how happy we are together
the boys look at the boys he's not a bad
guy look at his smile he's sweet he's
dude his hair is on point how old is he
no doubt I think he's up there what a
guy he's wise I mean how long has he
been in power and a democratically
elected too I'll say
um
why are you laughing uh for about a
decade now I want to say a decade of
great service
by President Chief he is uh
uh he's 69 nice by President chi chi poo
poo head
just to give you some perspective on
this between Instagram and Tick Tock
Lena posted the same video on both
platforms yesterday 5 000 on Instagram
750k on tick tock
Instagram is [__] they don't you
don't get discovered there's no
Community Instagram will never replace
Tick Tock and you would know that if he
used it Dan you're out of your element
you had a problem you had a banger on on
Tick Tock Lena another one I do yeah
about the my ring cam for my car
oh
wait wait is that where people were
yelling at you that the police are going
to spy on you yeah
but a lot of people are saying that um
yeah cops are going to be spying on me
well unironically you should be more
worried about that than China spying on
you because the cops have a lot more
that they could do to you than wait what
do they mean what do they even mean that
the cops will spy on you uh the ring
Amazon uh gives like pretty much
unfettered access to law enforcement too
do you think they'll just well no they'd
have like there's there's stories about
it
[Laughter]
happening law enforcement oh guys look
at this it's not set up yet but we got
it
the twenty thousand dollar
it's remarkably light I have to say this
is like one pound you want to grab the
box that comes with it yeah because this
it by itself is not super impressive
this is audio this is video and I love
how big the buttons are because it's
like an emergency
you can't miss it
so then it comes with this giant box
what the [__] is in that thing that's a
heavy thing eh yeah please be careful
maybe
here's what 20 000 buys you in broadcast
shredders shaky hands getting shoved by
the dogs here let me hold it holding
this
wait I'm more afraid of it yeah
Power right there bro please go put it
down it's very sensitive equipment
nervous very nervous we waited a long
time and spent a lot of money on that
thing you think it'll be ready by Friday
well I without getting too technical I'm
gonna have to redo
the whole signal flow of the studio to
integrate it
um for a number of reasons I'm going to
be sending it to a different computer
the delayed feed yada yada so
um I we don't have leftovers tomorrow so
I will have a decent amount of time okay
if I can tackle it
um there's a few other parts a few other
parts that I need that are ordered that
are supposed to be delivered to today so
if everything comes uh I might be able
to get it done by Friday that's if not
it'll probably be next week sometime
that's exciting
I really think it's not only going to be
effective but fun I think we can have a
lot of fun with it you know what I'm
saying yeah
far more fun that's that's what I'm
worried about yeah so anyway I'm hoping
maybe Biden just uses that as leverage
because you know China is considering
giving Russia arms so here's the thing
it's the Republicans that are pushing
for this that article that you just read
oh they cross party lines when it said
it was approved uh divided among party
lines it's the Republicans that voted to
give Biden authorization why how is it
that the Republicans are always Crossing
me I thought for this one time maybe we
were aligned our goals were aligned but
no they [__] crossed me every time
yeah well a lot of uh the Democrats are
um
you know talking about doing this as
well but uh they from the article it
said they voted no because they want to
investigate a little bit longer to make
sure it's legal necessary to do it
that's smart um yeah whereas
yeah I mean uh the Republican party is
the primary uh anti-china sentiment
party I mean white boy but I'm not
stupid they're the ones that are
claiming that Tick Tock is like a
national security threat
I say more Tick Tock I say tick tock
should be downloaded mandatory on
people's phones like the YouTube album
right yeah yeah that went over well
um okay so anyway our thoughts and
prayers to tick tock
thank you thank you [__] You Ryan
Kavanaugh you dumb [__] loser [__]
dumbass loser drunk [__] drunk ass
[__] your wife is getting railed by a
giant [__] Israeli dude with jacked
huge Jewish [__]
and your wife loves it
are they you just you you stand in the
closet and listen as your dick is in a
[__] cage are they still still married
and they
they get divorced what Dan do they get
divorced no it's on their Wikipedia page
it says they're still married uh well
it's Wikipedia so his Wikipedia page is
accurate as it gets I thought I thought
we saw something at one point uh on his
Instagram I thought he posted like we
had a great relationship but time to go
our separate way if it's the second wave
Jessica it says they're divorced oh oh
so it's updated so he is divorced okay
twice divorced okay so this is an
important
this is an important correction I'm
going to make on air he is twice
divorced he obviously is a great spouse
um
he managed to stay married at least last
time for you know eight years so that's
pretty good eight wonderful years eight
wonderful years that's right
I'm sure she wasn't
for all
how what a piece of [__] are you bro no
woman can't even settle down with you
you're apparently rich and still you're
just so disgusting obviously is he dyed
his hair like it looks like he has hair
dye on his [__] forehead
yes yeah he does this anyway he's a
[__] loser he has a lot of redeeming
qualities too
he's brought a lot of uh Joy To Us in
this audience
it's true indirectly
so that's fun that's true we've had some
laughs also I I gotta I Gotta Give Ryan
Kavanaugh some credit yeah
there was a uh for Hassan's uh uh
earthquake Relief Fund
they raised 1.3 million dollars I gave
ten thousand and one dollar to that
right but I have a sound bite of Ryan
1.3 million dollars oh [__] 1.3 million
that's right on the nose big supporter
that is right on the nose man
yeah he's got a really good
right up here drive angry in 2007
Kavanaugh presented habitat with gaming
for an oversized check pledging one
million read his Wikipedia page every
time you pull it up he played he this
man walked into a charity event with an
oversized chat for a million dollars
however as of 2015 Kevin has yet to
donate the promised funds right yeah
2015 was a long time ago maybe he got
around to it yeah right that guy's broke
his [__] he's putting every penny owns
trailer
yeah he's a good guy
weekend
the great uh you know what's funny this
lawsuit is probably going to end up
because he has legal issues now I'm part
of your story douche welcome I'm gonna
be a [__] footnote on your Wikipedia
page douche
yes
he said I'm a toy podcast well play with
these nuts [__]
thank you
and his ex-wife doesn't play with his
you know what they call this Friendly
Fire Brad the bull was squirting a
little too wildly that day
that is horrific and
[Music]
all right anyway I don't know how we got
into Kavanaugh but there it is we love
him he's a good because the Thriller and
Tick Tock we we kid our good friend uh
Ryan Kavanaugh
big Nick a friend of the show
this guy is so lost
David broke him man
he became this like
born-again Christian and he's like
such a little piece of [__]
and I don't say little because of a
stature I say it no you would say to his
actions and words
um yeah yeah he's kind of just full of
Christian fascists now it's crazy bro
that's what happens when David [__]
with you for long enough
here check this out
that's prices oh I'm always about
lowering the gas prices for sure why
absolutely uh well let me refresh we
missed the okay you know what you're
never gonna make it Instagram if you're
not [__] if you're hoping this [__]
muted
yeah Instagram you're never gonna make
it man how are they gonna compete
or low gas this little startup Instagram
what the [__] did he ask always about
lowering the guy how am I supposed to
see the volume that's why it starts
music like that it's very annoying why
the f I dress on me how am I supposed to
see the volume at the beginning of this
video
you have to watch it all the way through
because you can't rewind either
lowering the gas prices for sure why the
question is
a demonic movement created by Satan
the biblical order that God created
um right and you know not to be rude but
if you go back to the Old Testament days
I'm pretty sure they would have [__]
thrown him in a while
like to be totally honest
I I like just being real he he Longs for
the days of the Old Testaments right
they would have [__] grout they would
have
I'm just being I'm just being honest
they would have killed him as a baby
they would have [__] that he'd be in
like from a circus show or something
like they he would they would treat him
like he was a demon Friday the button
Friday and thank God we live in a
society today that that has moved beyond
that and sees that we're all people and
we're all valuable and and worthy of
love and have you know but like he Longs
for these old days where he would not be
viewed as a human being
like straight the [__] up dude I do not
know if that has any
historical basis I was just gonna
genuinely don't know I don't know you're
telling me during the Salem Witch Trials
this dude comes out talking about burn
the witches they wouldn't throw his ass
in the well I I definitely not by Salem
Witch Trials days
ancient uh Israel and stuff I I can't
speak on actually I I'm interested if
I'm actually on to something or not
well we can all agree he wouldn't have
as much uh people wouldn't be as gen uh
you know accepting as they are today
you can agree on that right Dan
there is a Wikipedia article about
dwarves and pygmies in ancient Egypt
they were treated with considerable
respect that's not I couldn't enjoy high
social positions Egypt this is not where
we're going
I'm just reading this article that
popped up when I looked for it so what
he was like I'm just kind of curious he
was he was like a god they they
celebrated it yeah at least in Egypt you
know I don't care about what they did in
Egypt this is in the Old Kingdom Period
which is yeah definitely Biblical times
we're talking 2500 BC ish no no no no
we're talking about like Spanish
Inquisition times that is that's what
that's what totally that's that's Middle
Ages that's like Christianity prime time
I think you're thinking of Westeros West
no you're talking yes so you're talking
about when Catholicism dominated Europe
and okay you know that's not biblical
times necessarily that's not what I
meant yeah in biblical times Jesus was
like a nice dude and everybody was like
DNA history what is that term
foreign
geez I don't know
I don't even drive like a gas powered
car I drive a Tesla I just don't like
feminine sick what's up it's cringe
unlike you protect feminism or low gas
prices oh I'm always about lowering the
gas prices for sure why absolutely uh
well I think feminism's a demonic
movement created by Satan to emasculate
men to get him out of the biblical order
that God created
um and
yeah you can just walk off bro
you don't have to finish that thought
the umbilical order
and I don't even drive like a gas
powered car I drive a Tesla I just don't
like feminism
so it's cringe
bro you cannot be serious right now
Violet l
donated five dollars and said I majored
in medieval history in the Middle Ages
people thought you were demonic slash
Unholy if you were disabled I knew it
that's what I was saying okay well you
didn't say that medieval once you
clarified that's okay Christianity was
like swinging it was popping baby you
know the kings were Christian okay and
as you know Christianity made Europe a
beautiful peaceful place when it
dominated Medieval Times in Victorian
England people with uh dwarfism were
kept by kings and queens as pets for
entertainment and that's what I'm saying
they were they were not viewed as human
beings so Middle Ages yes all this would
have made a lot more sense because when
he says I want to go back before
feminism I feel like that's when he's
talking sure when men were men and women
were women
so I think I have a good point
watching a wiener
I'm dreaming of my next Tucker
I dream of a good righteous England I
thought when tacos were Tuckers
and dwarfs were locked up as did the
demons we knew they were
I dream I dream I dream of adjusting
land
sharples that's not your ID
where dwarves were locked up and
uh
they were locked up and uh what's uh
exercised
the only place I would see a dwarf was
in the custody of our good Lord who made
them sing and dance with an umbrella
feminism is a satanic plot
I long for the old days when women were
women and dwarfs were slaves
that's right
I think I do have a good point
even though I don't think any other way
honed in on the medieval What drew me is
when you said biblical okay yeah
medieval times so you back me up are you
co-signing my point uh yeah they're okay
disabled people were treated very poorly
in medieval times that is 100 sure
somebody tell Big Nick
thank God we live in a day where you
know people are more tolerant accepting
it's awesome because if I was Jewish I'd
probably be killed too bro I'd be tap
dancing right next to you
oh
you know I'd be tap dancing for my life
right there in the king's court
you would have converted you would have
folded you think so I don't think do
they give you a choice yeah oh yeah I'd
leave it it was it was converter died I
don't want to be a Jew I keep telling
you guys I don't want this you don't
think it's like some cool [__] like take
it bro I don't need it I don't want it
don't talk to me just leave me alone
well
turn yourself into the nearest uh
Cathedral next opportunity you got well
thank God we live in a PLA and you know
and big Nick you'd have to convert too
which means I think what they would do
is they had [__] they would stretch you
bro
they had devices where they would I mean
that was a torture device I don't know
if that was they stretched them out on
little people
just saying
protect I actually want more big Nick
content I'm I'm uh craving it do you
guys have any more big Nick content
because it's just it's so interesting to
me how he's fallen so so hardinism or
low gas prices oh I'm always about
lowering the gas prices for sure why
absolutely uh well I think feminism's a
demonic movement created by Satan to
emasculate men to get him out of the
biblical order that God created
um and I don't even drive like a gas
powered car I drive a Tesla I just don't
like feminism
so it's cringe
dude you are such a loser bro
it's not his fault though David broke
him you put this on David I don't know
if you can entirely put this under he
was a normal dude until David [__] him
up was he herb well I think so he wasn't
a Christian
I thought he would that was always like
kind of part of his thing I'm looking
over to ABR resident Vlog Squad
yeah I think David used to make fun of
him for it towards the end of it
um oh he found God before yeah yeah when
he left right away he was saying like
David and the crew is doing a Witchcraft
and doing a bunch of Unholy [__]
oh
yeah that's what David's been doing
wrong
not the excavator
the Witchcraft did I live for Big Nick
takes actually all right it's official I
want to debate feminists on podcast Now
call in [__]
call the [__] in where you at big Nick
message him call him right now yeah
this is just from last month only like a
week ago
call me
Big Nick
I will be reaching out look for a DM oh
look at this [__] loser from whatever
he said come on Whatever Whenever you
bro come on whenever he actually he
damned me once I could I could shoot him
a message see if he wants to come on the
whatever guy no no big Nick message him
right now
call in right now big Nick how well
he'll take to a world you're a demon I'm
gonna exercise him right here on here
you're a demon Nick
he wouldn't touch my message he'd
probably be like that's a woman
absolutely not now Nick if you would
have called in here today
I need you to put 10 cloves of garlic
round your neck
cause you are a demon boy
I need you to do 20 Hail Marys
and spin around on your chair lock
big dick
the moment you were born
an earthquake hit
Indonesia
[Music]
killed ten thousand people
it's so [__] ridiculous
Big Nick
by the butt of the Lamb by the blood of
the Lamb God by the blood of the lamb
Big Nick I beseech you
hail Satan
uh what's this we have another drawn
quartering here big Nick I got something
for you
[Laughter]
so what's the medical values
but to know that they're wild all over
the place the Russians the Chinese
they've all got it going on
it's so funny it's just chiropractor
well that's how it was
over open fire I don't know if this is
chiropractor they're roasting his ass
so frantic oh yeah someone needs to
speed that up a little bit
bro
what could possibly be the benefit of
that
yeah actually that reminds me there was
another chiropractor video I came across
and listen I know a lot of you all swear
by it
um can you highlight it or tell me what
number it is
that that's the one no where's Oh I
thought where's the one where he's
driving yeah
I love it oh boy
I must have missed that one
okay and that's the one I thought it was
what's
it's awesome and it's in America too so
you know it's real medicine hell yeah
it's certified Nick come here now I got
a technique for you boy it ain't gay if
it's a chiropractor
sir this is making me a little
uncomfortable it ain't gay if it's a
chiropractor it's in God's name
amen well there you go we clogging up
the demon holder that's what we call the
butthole
this man is making porn on Instagram is
that what he does this chiropractor
that's literally what his contest that
was how he got on the chiropractor if it
is in the first place was it on
Instagram it was on YouTube but remember
the chiropractor videos that was just
softcore porn yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was like yeah
that now now I know
you got your demon hole here you put you
know it's a it's a one-way street that
demon hole we gonna block it up Lord
uh first time very first time I mean
what just happened I think you were I
think you were just essayed brother
just reset your AC joints okay let me
just reset those real quick
this part did you taste it
yeah you tasted spinal fluid it gets
even more vulgar
taste it I could literally taste my
crack
oh what was that
where am I where am I what happened
it's really helped that you could tell
it's good medicine
this is my the best thing
this man is literally driving a steak up
his [__] you think he was told to say
I could taste my crack
you think let's watch this again okay
oh wow
he seems genuine
seems like a general I think he's being
he's being cracked for sure I don't
think he was instructed to say that but
I could be wrong did you taste it
yeah I could literally taste my crack no
that's actually uh I haven't washed my
hands that was uh what the [__] from the
bathroom apologies you say this guy's
doing all other content that's
interesting oh I was just saying that
that video was literally like porn
written
that feels so good oh I wanted that
mouth boy that feels so good oh
[Music]
all right go right there drop your right
shoulder down oh oh Lord he did it to me
oh it don't hurt either yeah you're
gonna be fine yeah it's open yeah it'll
be fine that story where the person was
like paralyzed from their chiropractor
that one looks crazy
let's see this is a big dude right here
that that is just not a good I'm sorry
a private was like you're not supposed
to be in excruciating pain you're just
not
that's soft
okay
a steak a steak and mallet is not a
therapeutic device I refuse to believe
it
I'm not a [__] train track dude I'm a
goddamn human being got John Henry over
here
hold my beer
I think I'm seven foot tall now
what what I'm doing
yeah this shit's crazy I love this guy
this guy's awesome he's not afraid to do
the really wild [__]
oh this is just like what an insta story
why are you posting this bro 36 likes
don't post this crap this isn't a main
page post idiot do better dumbass idiot
all right yeah reach out to Big Nick
though I want him to call him
you got it
because he we talked to him before a few
years ago
yep yeah you had a very friendly
interview with him he's a friend of the
show
Mark Elliott update
someone made this Fire Emblem yeah I was
waiting to test see if it got claimed it
didn't
should I start it from 30 seconds
uh no from the beginning I don't know
why I sound like that in my bed have a
good night have a good night
one of those hated YouTubers on the
platform
I felt worthless
ugly I felt gay
[Music]
I felt worthless I felt ugly I felt that
no like that's based on what they told
me
yay
[Music]
today I feel uh gay and awesome this
rocks
oh yeah happy birthday Rachel happy 39th
love you
love Australia
no she's a little bit older than me but
that's okay
I reminded myself the two most important
words of my life I am gay
yeah this is fire
okay
they really did the research to find him
dancing they put in the work post a door
sub yeah nice shout out to glassyb with
a really philosophy man damn well done
that's good well done sir glassy B we
got to keep an eye on that person
yeah
um Mark Elliott's the guy who from
Nexium that we had a we talked with
he's been tweeting about me
of course
he can't keep my name out of his mouth
Mark Elliott after live this is from I
guess yesterday Mark uh after living
with tourettes for 20 years I never
imagined the day would come when I would
start making
when
I start over after limit threats for 20
years I never imagined day would come I
would be making videos having to state
that the claim I faked Tourette Syndrome
to scam people are demonstrably false if
you disagree with my stance on something
debate me no need to make up lies didn't
we just is that what we did
yeah pretty much didn't really have
anything to say for himself
have a have a good night and again
that's just my opinion it's not a
factual claim although
you guys might be very interested to
know we found some
I would say supporting evidence
that he has at least faked having
Tourette's at least one time that he's
admit to on video
absolutely I wonder what he would say
especially I mean Harry is talking to
his Idol uh convicted uh trafficker and
uh and uh
p word p-e-d-oist
uh Keith Ranieri listen to this [__]
this thing happened was after I finished
the 16 day over a whole summer you know
June to August did the whole 16 day
from may excuse me from September to may
now I'm back on the road speaking and
going around the country I did no more
ESP
um I don't even think I did any of the
one-on-one processes uh that have could
that I could have that I could have done
outside of a class the classroom
by that may I was showing up to my gigs
and my ticks were so low that I had to
start fake ticking because these schools
were hiring me as a speaker with
Tourette syndrome and I'm showing up and
I'm thinking uh
uh it was because I didn't know exactly
what was happening and
this man just confessed
to faking ticks for money
is that uh did I could I interpret that
right
he said I faked tits
[Laughter]
I faked having ticks so that I could
make money
that is a pretty
pretty big confession now as someone
with Tourette's I I never been
comfortable to fake it
I never fake ticks actually no I did one
time that's not true really I was being
it's sometimes you just people make you
feel like such an idiot I was being
recruited for the military
when I was in Israel
and I told him I have Tourette's which I
guess it disqualifies you for the draft
wait you fake ticks to get it out of the
dress no I didn't fake ticks I have
Tourette's but I went for the interview
yeah and they were asking me questions
and like I'm not my tics aren't always
visible right it's not always like yeah
and so they they're just they make you
feel like such a [__]
piece of [__] that's basically and so I
started doing like this you know but
that those are ticks I had yeah yeah but
I was like and then and then when I did
that I felt so stupid they're like oh
she he has ticks
ow no it it's and honestly if getting
out of getting out of being drafted into
the IDF is the one time I was not doing
the IDF bro I was not doing that I I was
not doing it so anyway I got an
exemption because I have Tourette
syndrome
uh and the one time I did it it just was
so horrible it felt so bad people have
have asked me in my life to do it and
I've always said no but obviously
that was uh worth it but I didn't make
money from it also I'm not telling
people my tourettes is cared stop it
here he is
yeah I was sitting there going I was
like
because I could tell they weren't like
buying it I was like I have Tourette's
what do you want me to do to prove to
you that I have Tourette's I started
going
laughs
they're like
literally it's so stupid such [__]
yeah but Mark Elliott said he did it for
money scaring me is this an incredible
Revelation from September to may now I'm
back on the road speaking you know going
around the country I did no more ESP
um I don't even think I did any of the
one-on-one processes uh that I could
have that I could that I could have done
outside of a class the classroom
by that may I was showing up to my gigs
and my ticks were so low that I had to
start fake ticking because these schools
were hiring me as a speaker with
Tourette Syndrome ladies and gentlemen
and I'm showing up and I'm thinking uh
uh I mean it was because I didn't know
exactly what was happening I mean it was
the whole thing was new and it was it
was exciting it was kind of scary it was
It was kind of everything in between
um so the frequency did change once I
see he he notes that I think what in
reality again this is my S this is just
my opinion he may have felt
relieved to finally get that off his
chest that through your therapy I no
longer have to lie about having
Tourette's in reality you guys got
scammed yeah no people are asking I
brought I had a doctor's letter a
neurologist that I saw when I was a kid
saying that I had Tourette's they wanted
to come they wanted me to come tick for
them like a
like a sideshow back in medieval times
to prove it huh
so I don't know I think this is pretty
compelling stuff
it definitely doesn't help his uh case I
mean based based on what he said and
this is just his words he faked having
Tourette's
at least at some point in his life he
said that
in this video he faked having Tourette's
that's his words not mine of course in
my opinion I don't even know if that's
true or not that's just my opinion
but I do find it quite interesting
oh glassy bees in chat can't believe you
guys are reacting to my music I have
plenty other tunes that he's
like he's skating oh I had no idea I
just need to
pre-vet them to make sure they're not
copyrighted but I'd love to listen to
another one if one of y'all want to
check
just do a little check on copyright oh
that was their YouTube channel wasn't it
classy B okay glassyb
glassy B Cuban B
so this is pretty bad
I was considering inviting him on again
to hit him with this but
was such a Flawless victory
that I wouldn't even want to give him
any other chance to say anything you
know what I mean
yeah he's just gonna come with some
[__]
so there it is Mark Elliott who has said
he fakes Tourette's
have a good night
I mean I had at least one phase of his
life he literally said I faked
Tourette's and again that's his words
just to recap here because I know he's
talking to his lawyer right now for ESP
um I don't even think I did any of the
one-on-one processes uh that have could
have that I could have that I could have
done outside of a class the classroom
by that may I was showing up to my gigs
and my ticks were so low that I had to
start fake ticking he says I faked
having I faked having ticks maybe he
didn't fake having Tourette's let me
amend that be more specific he said I
faked having ticks
so there that is huh
make a little Amendment there he said he
faked having tits not that he faked
having Tourette's now I don't know if he
has Tourette's it's my opinion as
someone with Tourette's that he may be
faking it but I don't even know that for
sure
it's just a fact in my opinion it's just
a fact in my opinion no it's not a fact
in my opinion it's just an opinion
period
hey love always wondered is your name
pronounced luve or love what
yeah the first one
this is why I don't know this is why I
don't think of one up it's so hard for
none uh but we pronounce it correctly so
are we not saying it correct no say it
again
[Music]
I Remember by Mr luvaluva but you don't
mind myself right no actually you're
wrong yeah it's still wrong
I prefer love yeah because I don't have
to deal with the mispronunction
mispronunciation yeah it's my
brother-in-law his name's sake
right good luck getting an American to
say that saki saki saki what uh what
language is that Hebrew oh it's Hebrew
oh and then and and here he goes by Zach
makes a lot more sense yeah gotcha
gotcha that brother-in-law yeah I feel
like there's a lot of languages that
doesn't where the names doesn't
translate well to English and
Swedish is one of them I guess
um somebody donated Dylan Sim says this
is the flesh God is a real liver King
who is that do we have any
um details on that person
this is the flesh God mm-hmm
just another one of those like raw diet
people I'm intrigued this is the flesh
God anyway good luck out there mark
Elliott I'm sure you're
got big big important things coming up
for you fighting
for the release
Keith Ranieri have a good night have a
good night
I love how he goes if you disagree
debate me is that what we just did
well
what does debate me mean
he was on I was on that call for a long
time
yeah I mean even after you reveal I
guess just because uh he came in not
understanding what he was walking into
he probably feels like he wasn't given
uh
the proper uh preparation
right that's what journalism is Buddy
okay and I am a real journey you're Mr
gotcha I miss you you stepped up to Mr
gotcha I'm Mr gotcha gotcha gotcha's
fall out of my mouth you remember that
commercial I missed her sounds familiar
[__] it uh Mr Buck Mr Bucket
right it's not though put your balls in
my mouth I missed the bucket The Falls
fall out of my mouth balls fall out of
my mouth [__] it's so fun
now did he say balls in my mouth put
your balls in my mouth I think he says
balls oh I'm gonna sound like I was just
remembering Mr Bucket pull it up
here's the commercial
hell yeah this is so nostalgic
what does he see he says put the balls
in my top on my top
out of my mouth
[Music]
James Mr Bucket the first to get their
balls into Mr Beckett wins but look how
good the balls will pop out of his mouth
pretty good it's still pretty good that
one really stuck with me yeah a Mr
Bucket Vincent Thornburg thank you so
much for the um support and love
appreciate you so much thank you for
that thank you
I'm Mr Bucket
so where are we man we are not we have
not even remotely gotten out of the top
of the show section yet there's so much
good stuff here and we're um hour 50
into the episode
uh
uh did this guy claimed Anna De boss
it did not so who is she Ariana Dubose
okay
um she
she came from Broadway she so she's a
singer
she's dancer first usually she played
Anita in Spielberg's West Side Story
um she it's a big one Academy Award for
it she's a very talented woman and she
was performing at the baftas about a
week and a half ago two weeks ago and I
guess she got bullied so much that she
erased all of her social media for this
she deleted her Twitter after this
happened she has since said that she
loves all the memes and gay Twitter
loves her so she's happy about that
um but she did delete her Twitter she
failed right after this happened that's
that's the best way to respond to that
and she didn't do anything wrong she's a
little funny
here's a little ditty she put together
for the ladies
[Music]
and girl you're a great blonde Danielle
D you broke my heart Michelle I've loved
you from the start
that's the part that I think got most
people
did the thing amazing
right now she doesn't really hit me as
the as the triple threat but apparently
she is from that performance it's pretty
goofy in there it was a goofy
performance
she has some killer Talent though okay
not an Angela bastard
woman King that one too
that's a lot of talent from this
performance don't judge her just from
I'm just saying I'm surprised she's the
triple threat
foreign
oh that was nice
[Music]
Carrie and Carrie with the sea that's
really her lyric carry it and Carrie
with the c I doubt she wrote it
must be real
well whoever wrote in you she's ruined
her whole life
so
I'm so fine
you broke my heart Michelle I've loved
you from the Stars
her shoulders too it's like really she
thought she was doing something she was
why is she so out of breath
things are happening
history
of us other ladies in the room her and
her team wrote it so I'm seeing in the
chat yeah I don't think okay that had to
be her it's just that bad it's just
really bad I don't know I've always
thought Jamie Lee is all of us Jamie Lee
Curtis I like this I love that she's
vibing with that like everyone else
looks fell shocked and she's just like
yeah just to be real I am a Jamie Lee
fan but how is she all of us
yeah this uh
uh
somebody Jaden said my neighbor's house
just caught fire send me pictures shout
out
thanks for the update put your balls in
my mouth hopefully call the police
that's uh
oh God my neck
Carrie and Carrie with us what an honor
she's honoring the great women here
tonight Carrie with a C
if she had said Olivia Lopes did the
thing I would be so honored right can
you imagine no it isn't on it is an
honor
I'm so fun and a girl you're a gray
blonde Danielle D you broke my heart
Michelle I've loved you from the Stars
it's like she's
on another planet for that verse anyway
pretty funny I don't know but one of the
chats she sounds like a Canadian from
South Park buddy
oh wow I hear it thank you Jesse for
that though no appreciate that
horse girl Jesse
also we have an update from the dude who
said if you don't have a Lamborghini by
oh no it's erased oh boy no no it's here
it's here it's here this is the dude we
watched the clip he said if you don't
have a Lambo by the age of 20 you need
to take a look at yourself in the mirror
because there's so much money out there
especially with AI
there's so many scams that you could be
running
put your balls in my mouth so here he is
with another fresh take let's take a
look guys don't like hanging out with
girls we don't like to have fun and hang
out with girls we like to sleep with
girls we like to attract girls if we
want to just have fun and we don't want
to like have that like tension that
flirtatious dude you cannot put that
music over anything and expect it to do
something this isn't inspirational it's
just weird
if we want to just have fun and we don't
want to like have that like tension that
flirtatious tension or end up taking a
girl bro what's up I'm glad to hear the
clip music is drowning it out and we
don't want to like have that like
tension that flirtatious tension or end
up sleeping with a girl we would prefer
to hang out with guys that's just the
truth guys yeah I think liking I think
hanging out with girls is pretty gay too
yeah girls are gay
I just want to hang out with the Bros in
the shower at night on the court
girls are gays I like to end the night
with my Bros
wake up with my Bros
ah damn I'm back bro
the song they use this beach house too
which is just a guy and a girl
okay wait there's a girl Beach House
Eagles women are just good for yourself
so let's be honest when I'm not [__]
when I'm not using them like a [__] doll
I want to hang out with the brothers
[Laughter]
and I like to hang out with them even
when I am having sex I like to just so
we could play Madden
yay okay don't like hanging out with
girls this poor guy he's like 20
something and he thinks he's actually
like saying something interesting
[__] you're so embarrassing though to
have fun and hang out with girls we like
to sleep with girls we like to attract
girls but if we want to just have the
guys and we don't want to avoid that
like tension that flirtatious tension or
end up sleeping with a girl we would
prefer to hang out with guys that's just
the truth guys damn girls are just not
fun or funny or interesting to be honest
I just want to put my dick in them and
then go back to the boys
honestly if my boys had vaginas I'd [__]
them
no question honestly one if one of my
boys presented his ass [__] to me I'd
[__] him imagining you have a vagina
oh the [__] yeah
I heard um hunger FF call it his ass
[__] or something so yeah he did refer
to it as that it's just so it's so
vulgar
oh [__] okay
Angela
Angela Angela
thank you Sandy Martinez ten gifted we
love that thank you thank you
speaking of these cringy Alpha
influencers fresh and fit still because
thinking about me apparently as he goes
about his day
I have not talked or thought about this
man
and he keeps tagging sneako like he
really needs his friend's approval
that's so weird he says he's I guess
he's running is that what this is he had
someone film him running
you had someone film you running bro who
filmed this
right who filmed this
this is it it's fresh this is coconuts
and Barbados just following him around
he's in Dubai I guess on vacation and
he's saying no I'm out here running and
somebody's filming it
he said or I could have quit like lasan
Lobby or lethan decline
but then I remembered I don't kiss dudes
[Applause]
awesome dude [__] this is such a
weird
yeah such a weird Avenue to take I mean
he's implying that due to people who
kiss dudes or women too
um
are quitters
yo you kiss dudes you just didn't try
enough
well here well that's not it the funny
part is up next his next story it crash
cuts to him in a restaurant or bar
okay
with like some kind of male belly like
what is this bro this guy I'm not gay I
mean it couldn't it couldn't very well
I mean the dude having the most fun
there no [__] way
in the [__] bass this man's reading
and then the next one is this book why
women deserve less
by him
oh he wrote it look it's Myron Gaines
that's him dude you're so read my own
book you're so funny
you're so funny dude
I really want to analyze that that gay
club shot I don't kiss dudes well if
he's in Dubai I'm gonna Hazard a guess
and say it's probably not a gay club
because well I don't think that they
have those well this is an openly okay I
mean the image is hilarious and it has
the vibe I don't know Dan this is a gay
man living his best life
I think they're tolerant when like um
immigrant quarters because they allow
drinking immigrants to drink and stuff I
mean this is a bar
yeah I just don't think that uh there's
a full-on Thanksgiving gay clubs I don't
think they'd let that fly
bill I like to imagine that it is but
the the yeah and I mean the visual is
[__] hilarious it's definitely not
like a super Alpha environment uh
certainly not it's got like uh
Moulin Rouge upstage and a gay dude
living his best gay life
let's see are there gay clubs I just
sent you an article that says 10 best
gay bars in Dubai never mind there it is
clearly he also visited that article
never mind and
wow okay there you go you see they they
know that they gotta welcome the um
they gotta reach across the aisle
you know what I mean
Angela Davis
wow
what'd you say then this
why do people
with peace and love
put your balls in my mouth this article
that uh Olivia sent you know it's like
the top 10 gay clubs in Dubai and I'm
looking through and like the first
paragraph is like it's the Vegas of the
East fantastic nightlife here's what you
need to know homosexuality is illegal
all across the United Arab Emirates and
in some cities it's punishable by death
yes at that point I'm probably bailing
on my trip like if I'm gay and I was
thinking about going to a gay club and I
read that it's like ah maybe I'll just
click I'll go to Paris and then in bold
it goes here's a list of gay bars and
clubs
there's only a small percent of chance
that morality police will be waiting
outside to execute you
yeah I'm not going to any [__]
country that kills gay people yeah
that's all these people like that I I I
just think it's so weird that all these
people go gala gala galifanting
galavanting
galavanting around Dubai and you know
the Emirates and and it's like you know
these people like killed they just like
kill gay people there and trans people
and have slaves all of the like
descriptions of the places say like the
staff is gay friendly and very with the
bar is welcoming towards gay people so I
don't know if they're very publicly
branded as gay clubs yeah you know it's
underground welcome it's probably a lot
of it underground and you just have to
keep it low-key but yeah when the uh
when the punishment is uh execution yeah
that's scary you just might not want to
bro I'm not going there
they catch you someone puts a little
weed in your pocket they [__] you they
throw you in like the Trent like a
[__] hole with some like space
Monster eats you
Rat Hole [__] that place rancor
yeah rankers sarlacc pit guy you know
the the princes there have rankers pets
they just do it like that
um let's see what else we got
I did want to talk about this
um how do we create a bigger tent
because I saw I know this is a problem
we have in our community it's almost
like an ongoing joke at this point that
if you're not a fan you have no idea
what's going on
because of the amount of inside jokes
and running lore
and so here's a post that I thought was
interesting
on the subreddit says I watched the HP
podcast for the first time because I
followed the Nexium drama became an
instant fan I want to watch the show but
I'm lost
um
it says I have never seen H3 before this
week and I watched Ethan destroy Mark
Elliott of Nexium on the podcast
and man that was satisfying I watched it
about four times it was so good thank
you
although Mark Elliott could have cured
your Tourette's and the amount of time
it took you to watch that four times
just saying it's not an interesting use
of time no you could have cured anything
he was in Nexium I want to watch more of
the show but I am lost in a sea of
inside jokes about all the about all the
hosts and what seems like YouTube drama
which I've never followed and don't
understand I don't know who Tanner or
Shane Dawson is for example and why
everyone's confused about another host
who might be a look-alike or something
I don't even really understand the point
of the show is it interviews is it like
Howard Stern is it a variety show is it
mostly about YouTube drama I could go
back to the beginning and start watching
the very first episode but be honest I
don't think I have the attention span
for that I wouldn't even recommend that
yeah
can someone give me a cheat sheet or
quick things I should know or episodes
that are a must wash so I can catch up
how would you explain this podcast to
someone like me so I thought this was
actually
you know this is a problem how do we
bring more people into the tent how do
we make this
you know show uh more inviting to
to Outsiders
are you just opening this to the floor
yeah Oh I thought you had no I don't
have a single idea this person
recommended
um something that was in there that
immediately sparked a thought in my mind
is what if we curated a in like a HP
podcast 101 playlist that's just like
10 to 15 episodes of like key
developments in like the lore of the
show so that it's like no you don't have
to go watch at 500 episodes or however
many [__] episodes we made at this
point but if you watch these 20
you'll dip your toes so so Howard Stern
has a channel called
sternthology where they go back and do
that they have like segments that
explain like the classic moments in the
show so I wonder if that'd be a good
idea for the highlights channel to have
a or maybe even the main Channel I'll
have a highlight
a playlist of uh h3ology or whatever I
don't know what's a good name for it
right what do you guys think about that
idea that'd be fun I feel like a fans
would want to go back and watch that too
so it might not be a bad idea to upload
I think that's a good idea but also we
have so many like new memes every single
week so that may be a problem I feel
like we need to set up stuff a little
bit better to our new audience sometimes
when we're talking about stuff but I
can't sit here and explain everything
every time not everything but I just
mean like I feel like we have a bad
habit of just assuming that everyone
knows what we're talking about even
people who are fans I feel like they can
miss an episode or two and be completely
lost they're not like so deep into it
yeah honestly
I just don't think that's super viable
like it's like it's really
I agree it's really uh takes a long time
and takes you out when you have to
explain every goddamn thing but I think
I think people like the idea like a
lower H3 lore playlist well what's uh in
their post what was like an example of
something that they didn't understand
well he says
uh
uh I don't know who Tanner Shane is and
I don't know why everyone's confused
about another host who has a look-alike
I don't even understand the point of the
show another host that might be he's
talking about Zach or imposter me or
something you know what I mean oh okay
he's like what is this and I get that
um so H3 crap
crash course that'd be fun I think we
should think of a list of uh important
lore moments
iconic uh clips and stuff
and maybe we can even take fan
submissions
because it's hard to remember all that
[__] done so much
yeah and it's hard to know what to focus
on because like they mentioned like I
don't know who tana and Shane are well
that's like that I can't help right it's
like well are we gonna explain just all
of YouTube history it would be funny to
have a glossary maybe we should do like
a funny like self-aware infomercial type
thing of like hi this is the H3 podcast
like a Cheesy intro video explaining you
know what the show is like here are some
things you should know here's the
orientation video I'm the host and I'm
this orientation media that's actually
kind of fun I'm the host
if you're sensitive to bomb threats you
may not want to watch this yeah exactly
but you can just like you can rattle off
like
okay
um
you know uh this is Ryan Kavanaugh he's
the owner of a big Media company I'm
currently in the midst of four lawsuits
with him uh I smoked crackers once I
once smoked crack we used to have a show
called Frenemies it was very popular The
Fallout of it is still reverberating to
this day so I think what would be good
is to have because there's way too much
stuff to do in one but it would be nice
to do like a a a Anthology so we can
bring in clips and we can bring in me
explaining it would be kind of Fire
hi my name is Ethan Klein Ryan
Kavanaugh's wife was [__] this jacked
Israeli dude and that's why we call him
Brad the bull
and we could do a whole episode just
dedicated to it or maybe it's better as
like an edited video a whole episode
dedicated I think people would like that
yeah I think so too we talk about
everything I mean it would be nice to do
that maybe and then what we have to be
careful when we're doing that show to
set it up in a way where it can be
uploaded yeah in in that show there
could be a section where like important
sound bites or something we go back to
the origin explain like why
this is funny in the first place when
it's played well that's what we do on
the sound bite tournament well oh H3
Iceberg somebody suggests yeah do an
iceberg video sorry go ahead Olivia oh
sorry the sound bite tournament it took
us back to it wasn't the actual video
itself it was the H3
clip rather than like watching the full
like where it came from
you know what I'm saying
yeah I think like a podcast history
episode just what important events that
happen each year maybe and just oh just
Summarize each year and that could be
interesting yeah we could talk about
Bill Burr ruined my life I do see a lot
of people uh Bill Burr made Ethan going
Lexapro I see a lot of people suggesting
creating an H3 fan curated Wiki
which is planet H3 Wiki yeah there is
there is well it's not a week it's like
these Wiki websites I don't think people
really reference those I mean if we like
direct people towards it though it might
you know how wikis are but like if
you're behind us if you're trying to be
a fan of the show you're not going to go
read a [__] Wikipedia I think videos
is good videos is the best oh I wouldn't
say only that I would just say in
supplement to that so like you watch the
orientation video now you're kind of in
but then you're still not going to get
all the references and if something
strikes you that your curiosity you go
and uh reference the wiki well if you
want to do that there is one a website
that does wikis for certain fandoms like
here Wookie tube H3 I don't know
it's probably right that one is there's
actually a lot more here than there's
actually a lot of stuff here [__] well
there you go
I feel like Pavements
okay keemstar tweeted that anti-white
race is unacceptable even responded
saying white isn't a race [__]
which he deleted minutes later he was
ridiculed for the statement by
White supremacists
you deleted that why would you delete
because I didn't want to deal with it I
was like I I may be a white boy but I'm
not stupid it wasn't worth it I Saw The
Usual Suspects winding yeah and I was
like I don't want to deal with this
people saying you all have to moderate
the wiki no that's the beauty of wikis
man this self-month self-perpetuating
thing you the power users they
you know
they they do get out in the marketplace
of ideas and I think we need a moderator
I feel like if you're really dedicated
to like kind of get all the memes just
start watching ask questions on Reddit
become a member ask things in Discord I
think like that's the crash course
you'll you'll get everything watch
highlights all the highlights and stuff
like that not everybody I mean that
works for you love but not everybody's
got the patience for that I'm trying to
think of someone like my mom's boyfriend
Steve who's trying to be supportive of
me and watch the show but he's like oh
it's you know it seems fun I'm just
always so lost like what how would you
describe the show you gotta tell them
keep up [__] I always say
be on your toes I always kind of tell
them that it's sort of like Howard Stern
on the internet like that's the best way
to describe it's true if as a Howard
Stern fan when I first got into it I
just had to listen to a lot of it to get
through it and I listened to
strenthology that was actually the
sternthology is probably the best thing
I listen to to get me up to speed with
it I agree completely over here yeah so
maybe that's the way to go like that I
think something like that yeah okay
let's talk we'll do a little meeting
about it and think about what's the best
way to do it okay
someone says new employee idea H3
historian
s
it's just a comment
Jesus Christ sorry bro sorry sorry sorry
that kind of hurt it's just a comment I
just read it I didn't even endorsement
or anything
your balls in my mouth
so there was that that was uh
there was uh we have this big segment we
should probably get to because it's
already uh getting
we're like an hour and a half into the
show yeah let's do this next I just need
to go to the bathroom
here we go and then we'll go ahead and
go into the main segment here which is
that the crew is going to be giving me a
makeover ladies and gentlemen
I'm very excited to try my outfits I am
going to go to the bathroom for what
potentially maybe five to ten minutes
don't try and pull that McDonald's [__]
on me dude you know no more than that we
should maybe just explain the lore every
time Ethan goes to the bathroom
just every time he goes to the bathroom
another year
okay what do you want to explain this
time
let's start with 2017 and the start of
the podcast
Dan when did you join the podcast
it was in 2017 yeah sick
yeah I don't really want to do this
right now though there's an important
piece of uh bathroom lore of this show
and that's every bathroom break Ethan
takes we promote Zach Lewis arrive at
live at the Roxy thank you Cameron May
13th thank you very much I do appreciate
that I love you Zach I hope there was no
tension between us earlier we're all
Gucci I love you Cam I love you with all
my heart I love all you guys love you
too love you too bud love you so much
and I can't wait to see you live at the
Roxy 13th May 13th May 13th at the
Roxbury baby
Town Seattle this is gonna be the last
show I do in LA for a little bit really
yeah I'm going on tour uh I just I want
to hit some other areas interesting so
if you live in LA or local L.A
took a last chance to see me in La for a
little bit did you get people coming
from all over to see you too I've talked
to people coming from Utah from Mexico
City Mexico City Canada
um Vermont
um there's a lot of great people that
come so you want to come meet some great
people here's some great Tunes
live at the Roxy May 13th ticket link is
uh if you just Google Zach Lewis Roxy
it'll come up or it's on my social media
I saw you put out a hell of an ad
yesterday Zach
I did
Zach you got to put your pants on right
Zach you could do the Rockies with no
pants on I uh I hung full dong so no you
didn't well my thong was like under
it was full too did it push uh push
sales at all they did well yeah did well
did you think that was real yeah Oh I
thought I thought that was like a
Photoshop no Chantal helped me pose nude
oh that's awesome semi-nude that's
perfect yeah so um that was a good time
and um Zach told me about that that
morning he was like I'm gonna take a
picture of myself tonight with my pants
off I was like that's sick
he told me about it too he was yeah
told everyone enablers
so yeah live at the Roxy uh I won't be
hanging dong there though are there
tickets left like you got to be close to
sold out at this point right where we're
getting there I'm just I'm gonna keep
pushing it and um we're almost there so
um
if you want to come I want to come Cam's
going to be there
but again I I have to redo it and won't
be hanging down there can't wait you're
sleeping over after if I'm allowed are
you are you going to be in the show okay
the tradition that cam sleeps over our
apartment at this point a VIP show it's
actually showing whole I'm not showing
hole there whoa
whoa friends and family the VIP section
that's plan Z if the tickets don't sell
Zach means it's a plan the first plan I
will bend over on stage this is the
primary plan show my my [__]
on stage live at the Roxy
so you want to see that
no promises though
huh I was gonna say convenient goes
avatars you can come as you want we come
as Navi you can come as Navi what's his
name Jake
solely if you want to come with Jake's
earlier if you want to dress up like me
hanging dong can I go as cocaine bear
you can come however you want let's all
dress up let's all go as fakes sounding
like that's all those fake Zach that
could be funny
laughs
but I don't know what you're talking
about well it's that Meme that everybody
keeps spamming oh right right like oh it
wasn't a reality I wasn't referring to
that yeah why do people keep saying that
I don't know [__] weirdos bro sorry
you're a real one Zach I don't know why
people say what are you talking about I
was here last week I was doing my job
what yeah I don't remember the last time
you took a day off dude it's been a
minute yeah
but anyways yeah live with the rocks
so how you guys feeling you feeling
confident about your fashion picks today
for Ethan uh I found I don't want to
give anything away but I found
I wasn't sure what direction to take it
I was kind of perusing around the
Goodwill I was like oh maybe I could do
this I was Finding like a few things and
then I found the golden item oh that
shifted everything is it made of gold
um comedy gold okay
Dan showed me I'm not gonna say anything
but it is [__] pretty fire right yeah
so I built the outfit around that item
that I discovered
I think wait Zach you've seen mine what
did you think
they're they're both really good which
one's better minor dance
that's so tough because I feel like
they're so similar in a way what yeah
all right don't say anything more why
did that why does Zach have all this
Intel because it's me it's me apparently
I'm fake dude this [__] is that the
wind still that is the wind I kind of
want to go on the roof and fly away
right now
you know what Cam that be badass I'll
lift my jacket up like this
and just fly away
so we said 25 in La Thrift Shop is not
that much uh most of us if not all of us
went to Goodwill which isn't like I know
what you mean a lot of thrift shops here
in LA are like actually pretty pricey
because it's nice condition older stuff
um but Goodwill is Goodwill and yeah I
mean I think most items that I got were
like three to five dollars or something
like that I got a full outfit yeah when
you guys were waiting to pay was how
long were your lines to check out no
line from no line two minutes one or two
people okay I waited 30 minutes what the
hell I waited 30 minutes
no here's the thing though there was one
it wasn't even that busy but there was
one register open okay and there were
like two people in front of me that were
selling a bunch of [__]
or donating a bunch of [__] to Goodwill
or something like that
um and so I waited 30 minutes longer
than I was looking for items
oh yeah that was fun
this whole idea was so fun I was walking
through um Goodwill and just laughing
the whole time just envisioning like
Ethan wearing dirt like ripped jeans or
pants any pants really it's just so
funny I had to walk away from her she
was cracking up the whole time I'm like
dude why are you you look insane right
now maybe I just thought of Ethan and
ripped jeans was cracking her I'm not
even I'm not entirely convinced that
what I got will fit him too that's a
concern of mine yeah I went
up just in case so I hope the pants stay
on
well [__] I forgot to bring a belt just
in case
where's Ethan
y's making making a poopy or something
making a poopy
uh actually I just remembered I have
something to plug not for myself but for
my girlfriend Ally she did a uh a
fanzine for people who are familiar with
those
for uh Final Fantasy Final Fantasy 9 and
she asked me to shout it out because
it's a it's a charity thing
is called
here I just pulled up their thing
[Music]
she drew the uh oh my God [__]
audio she drew the cover and the back
for it uh wow it's [__] sick dude
it's awesome and uh it's a very uh
specific Niche uh fandom but if you
happen to find yourself in there and
want to uh get something cool and raise
some money for charity
you can do it or if you just like
beautiful art or if you just like before
it's uh
ff9zine.car.co it's not a very good URL
but uh just look up you you are not
alone here and uh I'm sure you'll be
able to find it so anyways shout out to
that it's very cool Ally I'm about to uh
Reserve mine right now
sick sick [__] sick dude
let's see love for the whole crew
sincerely a 30 month member oh [__]
you're not lying Young crid
30 months
you might be close to having the record
there I don't see many 30 months Ethan
is 100 in line at doe bricks right now
yeah
crew chat's the best segment thank you
thank you uh can one of you guys tell
Ethan to pick me up two's cheeseburger
meal
he might be doing something like that I
don't know he's goofing on us
he's been gone for a minute I think he's
taking a poo poo uh next H3 live show
um it's in the works it's in the works
there's a dialogue going about it
um it will likely be in a larger venue
this time because we sold out the last
one so quickly we're doing at crypto.com
yeah yeah let's go Samantha donated 20
said rewind time is a fun title uh and
eventually a lore video in the style
Drunk History would be amazing it's
rewind time we all get really drunk and
high and retell the story of the issue
I'm there I'll be there and sit down
that does sound fun I'll be there
uh let's go okay
I agree I'm gonna get finger tattoos
that this weekend 23. finger tattoos
yeah come on I'm nervous but I'm excited
cam we call him finger attacks what are
you gonna get some flowers on my fingers
cool hold on they're very painful she
said I get one just on my pinky and
that's probably my most painful tattoo
let's go I'm gonna get painful look at
how tough I love Olivia's if I ever got
finger tats that would be my Inspire oh
my God send me a picture of your fingers
so I could show the tattoo artist yours
do you look cool yeah I think you can do
it it hurt but
if you care enough about how pretty to
look after then it doesn't matter I want
to look pretty so I'll power through the
pain you're gonna have beautiful
beautiful hands cam would you ever get a
piercing
um
maybe like a nose ring or something I
don't know but like a Prince Albert or
like a jig maybe I'll work my way to
penis talk somehow no come on now I
don't think I'm there yet but maybe I'll
have to work up to it Zach um no I'm
never gonna say no to something okay
fair enough I don't think it's for me
but maybe let's start with a nose ring
and then all the way down from you gotta
Lou read it take a walk on the wild side
yeah you know my artist once described
it Kim as a rite of passage sort of
that's how he looks at the pain and I
was like that's kind of badass to get a
princess yeah to get a tattoo no
I've completely gone to a point where I
just tone out Zach's dick talk at this
point
I didn't even hear that
it's a rite of passage my child
Juliana Ramos uh donated ten dollars
said Ethan read my comment I'll see you
next Tuesday but I hired PMP and I have
a court date March 28th let's go thanks
Ethan for introducing me but also he
called me Julia not Juliana yeah well
Ethan Ethan has a very special thing
with names if you haven't noticed 90
there did you guys show that Jordan
Peterson tweet
uh no no were you sending us stuff to me
I was oh we plugged the [__] toilet
oh no no that's what happened this time
so [__] what's the deal I I don't know
there's not enough tubes or too small
there's not enough water pressure do you
guys agree right I'm sorry but why don't
you flush in middle way through if I
ever have any courtesy wow courtesy
that's risky that's all I always do that
there was no intermission dude it was
one one law one big log
isn't the wiping that [__] it up
usually the paper no no [__] I watched
it
with this [__] clogged it dude yeah it
was the [__] holy big old dumps
I just I I don't know man it's like
somebody said get a plunger you absolute
Mad Libs we have a plunger that wasn't
the problem I don't want to go to the
plunger because it's just full of [__]
it's disgusting I do a I throw up a
prayer last time it worked by the end of
the show at all results itself is that
this I put the basket in front of it oh
man I can't what am I gonna do
during the show you want to start
plunging it'll resolve itself
all right we'll check after the show it
did last time okay yeah we'll see and by
the way
I even took the scrub and cleaned the
bowl last time that's very nice yeah
it's just the idea of oh it's disgusting
trust me it's not it's not ideal for me
either
it's [__] disgusting
the thing I don't even think I have like
you know
abnormally dense or massive crops it's
just those American toilets has any well
has anybody else clogged the toilet here
I know someone but I'm not gonna help
them I mean I don't know okay
was it me and I'm forgetting no okay
sorry about that guys but it is
we were having a good time so you go
back in there actually huh do you want
me to go back in there
ah all right so let's do this so guys
moving on to the hotly anticipated
uh
what are we calling this segment again
thrift store makeover totally
anticipated it was announced today and I
don't know what it's called it's well
it's a Goodwill style but it's not it a
Goodwill style how about that Goodwill
style it's the thrift store makeover so
I'm gonna go
so again the premise is this everybody
went to Goodwill a separate Goodwill is
that right for the most part
did anybody go together Ian and Sam went
together I I assume but
oh they did different wow you guys are
so committed we we spread out
the budget was the guide was to spend 20
as close to 25 but nobody went over
fifty dollars
and so how this is going to work is each
one of you put together an outfit
I'm gonna try each one on and then you
the audience will take a vote
to see who Reigns Supreme how we gonna
do the votes because they're so I was
gonna propose there's eight outfits
total
uh the simple YouTube poll lets you do
four so why don't we do four and then
we'll stop and we'll get a top two
from that first set and we'll do the
same thing again up one you just do top
one first one and then do one versus one
at the end yeah okay sure speeds it up
so here we go so I'm excited now what is
the thing here you guys think I need a I
need a makeover I mean what's the bottom
what's the underlining message here
and we just want you to have some backup
clothes in case you [__] your pants one
day
oh just sounded fun
D up you're like our Ken doll yeah yeah
okay yeah go ahead say it I'm gonna just
say what you want to say I'm a
disgusting Beast you can't dress himself
I know what you guys are saying
check this out I'm just kidding check
this out this Innovative new Korean
plunger yeah from shot just suggested it
wait it looks pretty cool you guys that
dude that thing probably works really
good wait yeah it doesn't work what am I
looking at it just it seals it and then
the pressure and then you like do CPR
yeah
you have to be pressing over the toilet
bowl with your hands I feel like yeah
it's totally gonna burst through and
then you're just gonna get dunked into
the [__] [__] I know what you're
saying it looks strong it looks like a
strong adhesive just don't give it
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation if that's
the product it better be goddamn strong
plastic seems a little wet can we see a
video of it working or something
do we really need more plastic in the
world when you just use the plunger I
mean the plunger works it's like
I agree but I I am curious how here did
you send a video oh we had it okay let's
take a look here we go
this is from three years ago so this is
old science it's like the lowest quality
I think it's sealed and so it's just in
the same way that a normal plunger works
it creates a seal and then the pressure
shoves your [__] down the hole
that totally works wait does he save it
no I'm sure it does work that what I
don't like is that it's clear and you
just stare your two your face is too
close that's what I'm saying I am not
getting over the shitty toilet bowl and
shoving my arms into it although on
another hand it's completely covered
when I'm plunging obviously my face is
yeah but like right it's the risk of
Splash there is a risk of Splash there
that's not false and that is horrific
when it happens
I think we just need stronger toilets I
need like jet engines under there
you know you've been on those toilets
that are like scary it's so powerful
yeah like the airplane ones
ain't nobody clogging those no all right
let's get started our first outfit comes
from Zach
that's right Zach so well let's let's
showcase each item or should I just get
dressed no no no I think you gotta you
gotta take the bundle of clothes so Zach
has for me a hat pants and short sleeve
his total was
23.97
each item was eight dollars yes it was
all right so it's just set me up with
that first outfit I'll go in there and
change all right they're going and let's
see now Zach this is a shirt pants and a
short sleeve and a hat or a hat I'm
wondering
I'm a little bit skeptical because
there's only three items there was a
certain Vibe I was going for and I'll
tell you the name once you are dressed
okay
um but uh I was just when you were in
the bathroom I was saying the line at
Goodwill was just atrocious really
30 minutes in line no there wasn't even
a lot of people it was just I think they
were understaffed or something maybe uh
well while you're changing we can
explain the outfit so there's not too
much like okay so I'm gonna go in and
put on Zach's outfit and then I guess
yeah you guys can set it up okay
wonderful so you did just kind of do
that so you're right
um
so are you coming around so live at the
Roxy the May 13th May 13th and then
Ethan March 13th May 13th March 13th uh
Ethan has a mic in the booth so hello
hello okay little hot turned it down a
little bit
um we can hear all of his uh grunting as
he changes and we have a shredder cam
sure hey buddy look at you he's the star
of the show star of the show you really
got me okay no this is the XO this is
good for you what is the inspiration
Zach okay so I call this uh Country Club
slob
um Country Club slob yes I think it has
100 not been washed there you go that
defines the outfit I'm serious this [__]
is nasty yes there's a very specific
like thrift store smell I feel like
they're definitely yeah say they wash it
but I don't think they wash it at the
thrift store no I think they watch it
they put lye on it they have to wash it
what do you mean they have to because
it's a liability a liability who's
showing Goodwill because their clothes
is dirty I did see a little uh that's a
great Point even I didn't see a little a
little bug in the Hat I don't know if
it's lice or something so what the [__]
up
so he this is a country club slob that's
what I was going for okay that went for
a real look here yeah expecting schtick
but this is nice stuff yes I I didn't
wasn't sure if we were supposed to go
you know funny or whatever it was
whatever your mind wherever your mind
took you is totally acceptable um and
you know I feel I like Hawaiian shirts
these pants did very well what they were
the biggest size they could find
what size is it it's double X it was
honestly the biggest size they had oh
it's a little big actually oh here's the
reveal oh
not bad not bad can you unbutton the
shirt too sure whatever you want how
many buttons uh just go down two yeah
two buttons I want to see some [__]
that's hot that is a little there we go
that's a five dude you look slim yeah
great the pants are too big
but uh I'm gonna Bunch it up so it
sticks so this is the so each item was
eight bucks
not bad
and I was thinking the shirt's kind of
nice yeah I was thinking you could wear
your your sandals I feel like that would
fit the uh outfit as well okay let me
throw those on I like the Hat I like the
I don't know it's just rocking
looks good yeah not bad
this how much you spent on that what's
that Dan and remind us how much you
spent it was uh 23.97 24.97 excuse me 20
under 25 bucks for that look that's not
bad well it seems to be a big hit
I walk into the bagel store you're at I
think that that guy is fun you think
he's a fine I see that guy and I'm like
that guy is fun that guy's an uncle yeah
sure Uncle energy you know what I
thought uncle that guy [__] dude yeah
sure [__] hard I'd say that man's
famous
yeah this guy plays the clarinet
plays a mean clarinet it's not a Batman
Zach oh I'm glad your shirt's actually
really nice yeah it's very looks very
good on you it's just a little see the
problem with this is like if I raise my
hands even a little right that falls out
right and that's not a good situation I
think that's part of the energy of the
outfit I agree if I was skinny and not
you know insecure about it I would
definitely you rock it with confidence
and so and no but nobody wants to see
that come on stop it it's like you're at
a coffee shop hey can you hand me that
can exactly I don't want that and then
you're always super insecure you're like
yeah if you're doing that if you're
fidgeting with it all the time you lose
the confidence and then it becomes you
know uncomfortable but theoretically I
like this look I'm glad I'm glad you do
thank you thank you very much well done
Zach well done
all right well who's up next
[Applause]
even I think mine's next Ian yeah Ian
yeah all right so let's get you back in
there to change
I'm gonna start setting up the poll now
too so round one the first one will be
Zach uh what was your title for it the
uh Country Club slob the country club
slob okay and Ian that's a good segue
what pending it what is the theme of
your outfit oh yours uh just sort of
night on the town in Hollywood I don't
know Hollywood Nights how about that
Hollywood Nights yeah Bob Seger so whose
look is this uh Ian okay so there's a
lot of items here at least yeah I went a
little pricey I don't have a camera by
the way that's not why I'm cutting no
I'm not cutting myself right now so Dan
is my avatar I will I'll move my mouth
for you go ahead okay
uh first I gotta commend Zach too he
spent 23.97 very affordable I spent
38.96 so I went a little over
an accessory I got killed on my jacket
as well
20 for the jacket okay well big spender
if it was worth it yeah
and we got a shirt that's size XL
yeah
okay you guys hear heavy breathing
a little a little bit a little bit a
little bit what is this thrift store
smell on the clothes it's like you're
that it's like a dead uncle like you go
to your dead uncle's house it's lie dude
it's chemical like just throw it on
there I think there's something
comforting about it in a way I would
agree it's a warm smell I would say no
it's a dead it smells like death
these pants I'm not sure they're big
enough I'm gonna try my best to squeeze
in here uh no these are not going to
close but let's pretend give it a shot
okay I got it you got it they're long
you show them
she's also died
okay this jacket's pretty interesting
okay okay all right here we go
all right that's a big reveal Hollywood
Nights baby that uh bathroom trip I
think helped button the pants you hadn't
done that I don't know if it was a few
lbs oh okay
[Laughter]
yeah did well yeah all of this the pants
wow oh what do we think Hollywood Nights
I'm into Hollywood nights no shoes I was
right here I'll put on my shoes I maybe
Barefoot is even better yeah I was gonna
say I think Barefoot kind of goes pick
the socks off if you could
talk me into picking out this outfit
today
a lot of us wanted to get shoes as part
of the outfit but the selection at
Goodwill is very bad especially like
sizes and everything see that's much
better you look like a hip uh Jeffrey
Dahmer
there's a great you're getting on that
Midwest train
well I don't know what do you guys think
what do you call this Ian uh Hollywood
nights I said uh do I not get the
fashion music where's the fashion Museum
there it is looks very slimming on you
it does look slimming yeah it looks for
saying that
so there you go
looking good stylish you can keep it if
you want this jacket is bonfire this is
like all different Ethans like if I was
born in a different place if I had
different parents what's this guy's name
Ethan incline this guy's this guy's name
is just e Venus guys
yeah all different flavors it's very
it's my boy we all had like a person in
in our minds like Ethan everywhere all
at once there's all these big Nick is
crying right now for sure uh actually on
that note uh he said he doesn't want to
talk to you
he responded yeah he said uh thanks for
reaching out but you seem pretty set in
your beliefs and he doesn't think it
would be of any value feminist
coward what I tell him I said he's a
coward show him that shirt make sure he
sees him a picture of me and send him
and say Ethan says you're a coward you
want to debate a feminist I'm serious
right now
actually let me let me go
all right big Nick can't stand the heat
you said he just a week ago
send him a video just cut to the butcher
all right so excellent another great job
Ian I got all right thank you let's
begin with Hollywood Nights everyone
Hollywood nights so I went over budge I
spent 30 and 96 as a reminder okay so he
we do have to deduct some of the uh keep
that in mind it was a little in your
voting a little overboard so who who's
next so they can get it looks like Lena
is next on the list Lena I got a feeling
Lena did me super dirty
no no
I think you'll like it actually I picked
shorts I tried to say it'll keep you in
your comfort okay all right Lena um do
you have sort of like a a name or a
title for this uh outfit sure the inspo
was Adam Sandler so so Adam we can call
it that I like that how about like
Sandler core okay I like it Sam liqueur
the total on on this one is 28.47 so
pretty good budget one oh I should I can
put the amounts as part of the poll too
what was yours again yes because you got
shoes
yeah and mine has shoes how much were
the shoes
um I think the shoes were like 14. the
shoes yeah they were 14. good deal
uh what was the total on Zach and yours
again Ian Zach was 23 and 97 cents
Ian was 38 and 96 cents
38 and 96. in shirt okay
I'm also compiling screenshots of all
the outfits so we can review at the end
of the film oh lovely lovely idea so
what was the name of this one it was
Sandler core Sandler cool yeah of course
so are we doing like a bracket thing or
how's this working we're just gonna
we're we're gonna do these first four
and then we're gonna do a vote and the
winner of the first four will go up
against the winner of the second four
got it so just very simple bracket the
winner I didn't say the shoes actually
biggest
so when there's a prize for the winner
there's a prize twenty dollars
say Sharkies oh hell yeah twenty dollars
of the Goodwill
the Sharky's thing is such an old show
me it was before my time I've never
actually had it it's quite good it's
actually good
Ethan goes back and forth all the time
the joke stems from the fact that we
were ordering it every day for oh I
remember right hating it
so it is good actually we just had it
way too much so it became sort of a meme
to [__] on Sharkies but Sharky's all
right here I come
Lena all right big reveal see it
this is not that different
[Applause]
oh
but hold on it's all about the shoes oh
my God look at that
you have never been more of a dad I've
never seen anything
you look like a Sandler in 50 First
Dates yeah
hahaha
dude the white socks with the new
balance is just so powerful what do we
think
he's chilling he's got no worries what
do you think Ethan yeah I don't think
it's that different than what I usually
wear except for the shoes I tried to
keep it a little bit closer something
you'd be comfortable wearing but I see
you with for the nylon shorts
I don't think I would wear obviously
this shirt is pretty loud the orange
but it's a five it's a Vibe it's a Vibe
it says I'm a dad
I don't give a [__] Lena were those
socks uh these are my socks oh those are
your socks okay
yeah this is Rich Jewish uh comedian
that's it I've made it in life yeah and
I just don't care anymore yeah that's
what you that's what you do I'm not
dating I've been married for 20 years
you look so much like my dad right now
it's crazy
I want to meet your dad I want to meet
that Dad no I'm not even kidding your
dad sounds cool
is he is he looking for uh work foster
kids
yes he called to adopt me and just be
like a stand-in sure yeah yeah all right
thank you Lena
nice job Lena nice job thank you thank
you who's next so we can get that going
that is incredible work it's a b next
and a b what
do you call your outfit and how much did
you pay for it uh I don't really think
of a name I'll just call it me
a b a b Corp ABS 2240s okay and 22 what
47 47 that's a good budget all right so
we're going abs
it's being delivered to Ethan in his
Booth right now
people are calling that last one
Whataburger core
that's kind of interesting I like that
yeah I feel that
okay wow oh it was a Whataburger shirt
uh
people have said that about me they say
what a burger
I think that shirt was a very special
orange I really like this
I like the orange I like the orange Cam
how did you feel about that
I'm not a big fan of orange but I it's
your one toxic trait my friend I bet I
hate the color orange just in general
you just like my blanket statements all
the way or halfway uh no buttons no
buttons no buttons okay
very good nice twill pants interesting
these are kind of nice huh
what the Twill
yeah this is I feel like this is
something
this is gonna be a new mode of Ethan
that we've never seen before yeah I
think so this is first date cool Ethan
well I gotta say uh without giving too
much away you guys you putting together
some decent fits for him here at mine I
think people will enjoy but it's it mine
is definitely
put together in jest that's what I was
expecting yeah most of these but I'm
happily surprised like I don't think
anybody will right here that he should
dress like mine all right here we go a b
core
[Applause]
I've met this person
exactly what this is It's the I've been
playing World of Warcraft for 10 days
and haven't showered yeah and I'm just
coming out to get snacks
it fits a lot worse than I thought I
would I was thinking to come out of
there looking fly the pants are way too
big you gave us you said two you said a
different pant size what did I tell you
it you said well I never told you my
pants size yeah you didn't yeah you
didn't 2XL yeah those are those are 2XL
well the problem is the waist fits but
the it's like I have a freak body you
heard what the Taylor said most people
with my waist size are like six five
figured I thought you're gonna come out
looking fly you're like a substitute
teacher so you still want this one
called ABS yeah because it's just like a
broke look like this this is just like
you're broke naturally but more you
shouldn't you're broke like yeah not
financially you look like Walter White
if you never broke bed where's his
velcro wallet did you get that this man
is single forever it looks like a photo
can you tuck it in um
like you're wearing your old clothes
this is the after she said the after
shot in the The Biggest Loser or
something true
you're trying to get all tucked in here
oh my God you're a teacher oh my God
you're my [__] bio teacher dude that
is it you look kind of like you're Mr
McGee [__] you look more like a teacher
you're Mr McGee right Mr McGee you look
like Robert Pattinson as well the way
it's tucked is really giving teachers
look like a PE teacher coach energy too
it's coach Klein pick up the page
up here pick up the pace guys come on
grab 15 minutes okay wait hold on hold
on hold on wait wait wait wait wait wait
look at the camera what if I was to say
you look like Tony Soprano I see that
okay okay maybe not leaving in your
hands like that a little jerk no this is
the soprano thing yeah but maybe like
yeah I guess maybe scratch your cheek
what the what do you mean oh she goes
what do you mean Tony didn't do delivery
I told Tony you got to do delivery come
here
well I can't believe this [__]
[Music]
I think I'm having a heart attack
foreign
listen I know you're my therapist but I
really like the way you look gabagoo
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right all right well listen we've
got four
um so I think uh should we put up the
pole here go ahead
oh yeah let's take a look at what cam
just sent here a little refresher nice
looks
you forget this is what you're what
we're working with here
's an X so we can get Salmon's next Sam
is next uh so Country Club slob
Hollywood Knights Sandler core or absc I
am going to put up the poll right now
here we go and I've included how much
everybody spent in the poll as well so
factor that into your decision
the idea was to get a good outfit out of
the smallest amount of money
all right
and We're Off to the Races oh we have a
strong early leader
what the [__] with Ian's Hollywood
Knights sitting currently at 52 I agree
that was a pretty far fed well how's the
vote going uh Ian is in the lead so far
I will point out that Ian did spend
significantly more
um but I did go way over budget that is
a
that is kind of like a hard thing to
quantify though the over 50 would have
been a problem but he stayed under I
will say
I'm not calling it yet because Zach is
gaining ground here uh I like every
update Zach is going up and Ian is going
down so we'd have a little bit of a l
Leon L I don't know if it's going to be
enough to surpass but Zach what's the
spread in the race uh Zach said 32 hands
47. oh that's a that's a done deal yeah
I mean Ian's Ian's healthily ahead it
was trending towards Zach oh Ian just
went down again the trend
is towards Zach so I'm gonna let it run
for another minute
yeah it was 32 30 46 now bro that's not
he's not gonna pass him I'm just saying
as long as momentum is still going in
that direction I feel like we gotta we
gotta see
uh it does seem to have stagnated here
at 32-46 though
[Applause]
so I think um I think we can call this
for e in Hollywood night congratulations
round one
very nice congratulations hey Zach I
really loved yours man thank you me too
me too strong second there thank you
thank you
I might have to show up and work one day
wearing that maybe let me know did you
send it to Big Nick I yeah let me see if
you said anything
God what did you tell him to read a
Verbatim
yo Sharkies I said Sharky's just gifted
100 memberships I said 200 200 I said
200 yeah 200. wait the real Sharkies I I
I have a suspicion of who this really is
that our Saudi benefactor I think it I
think it might be 200 thank you Sharky's
Saudi benefactor go ahead it is it is I
said uh he told me to send you this and
I sent the photo and he said LOL Bro
that's not what I told you I said
why don't people listen
I said tell him not everybody says
powerful as being a confrontational like
you but it's my words well you send it
to him then why are you talking to the
podcast or your personal personal okay
yeah we'll just say Ethan I'll go on the
podcast and I'll say [__] you to him
okay then say this Ethan there you go
you said you wanted to debate a feminist
so why why are you not taking this
opportunity
can I say Ethan said yeah yeah you could
say you think so okay
tell him that I said he was a he's a
[__] P.S love says you are a [__] what
was it that I said
all right as that goes down I'm ready
with Sam's look okay uh we did I'm sorry
Sam uh do you want to come speak into
the mic real quick and give us a little
rundown before we uh reveal
here and I'm gonna start setting up the
new poll here so round two will be Sam
all right Sam go ahead my look is called
uh Florida man Ethan please take your
socks off
okay we got four I want dogs out for
this one and Sam you you're the amount
that you spent was actually kind of
incredible how much did you spend I
spent thirteen dollars
that's gotta be a bonus for some time 13
all right I'm ready to come out
uh okay are we ready yep go ahead let's
do the reveal
it's Florida man people oh yeah the camo
shorts let's go dude that's [__] rad
oh and the cancel culture Corona virus
[__] tank up are you kidding hey yo
dude
on them just to flip it thirteen dollars
that that is incredible that's
incredible uh can you flip the bag Ethan
flip this right no in front of the other
side to the other side of the bag other
side of the bag flip it
oh wait wait beside this against your
stomach show the camera take the bag off
and rotate it there you go
and all right yeah
hell yeah oh yeah if we don't have our
rights to bear arms we ain't got nothing
that theoretical government's coming for
us guess what's in this bag I'll let you
take one gas spot that won't let me near
no schools with this bag I'll give you
one guess
just feel the beat
this one's for the boys
all right
um I do want to say in the you said 13
but I see in the doctor yes 22. yeah so
sorry I miscalculated it was 21.97. oh
no that's still the lowest though right
it's still the lowest yeah good but not
13.
I forgot about the bag the bag yeah the
bag was 11 bucks all right Sam's Florida
Man look
nice to see you very good very good all
right next up is Cam
if we want to get that one going and
Cameron do you want to uh give us a
little overview of your thoughts here
sure I mean okay it's called
EK by CG EK by
CG love that and uh Ethan said I mean uh
Ian said earlier that all of our outfits
probably we had somebody in mind I
definitely had somebody in mind oh my
God so I know exactly what you had in
mind well don't don't don't give it away
till you come out with a big reveal and
I hope you enjoy it and uh yeah I spent
I was a little over budget but I don't
know it's worth it
37.96 is Cam's total so uh a little bit
over budget but that's okay
um still not the highest and less than
Ian's as well so
in the middle of the pack actually I had
to put back shoes unfortunately that
would have completed the whole look but
you know
96. all right you okay back there you
ready to go yeah you're allergic to them
so
unsanitary alfredo
he's got a haircut looks so good
you look so handsome
all right all right we ready to go
almost
there's a lot going on here how's the
fit
I wasn't too sure about the fish a
little bit all over the place yeah
that's what I kind of assumed gets on me
yep
okay we got a jacket nice inlay
was there a good jacket selection at
your Goodwill because uh honestly
terrible this I found this jacket there
and I based the rest of the outfit off
of it oh okay so yeah I liked it but the
rest of the session sucks all right I'm
ready all right he's all right big
reveal time here we go EK by CG big
pants are super big so I gotta roll them
a little bit
hey
come on here we go come on out
all right
here we go
hold on I'm gonna come over real quick I
want to do a quick adjustment yo these
These are massive bro
hey I recognize that outfit
you're wearing
[Applause]
same jacket
no oh it has the same images
okay okay
I'll let you do it I just want to come
out for the gag yeah yeah thank you
you're not showing this
you guys look like uh you know what you
guys look like a French house DJ Duo
[__] that's Daft Punk right there dude
yeah I'm the idiot
so there it is how this is how it feels
to be Cameron nice yeah love it wow
powerful
appealing cam did you get your um
screenshot
oh I did not but I'm gonna I'll do it
don't worry about it okay I got it it
looks a little bit like the twins from
yeah whatever it's called Alice oh
Tweedle D and Tweedledum that's Ethan
and I right there yeah
boys
that's it that's what you get very hard
Cameron very nice very nice well done I
love it I love it Kim
love you Zach All right so
uh just two left right it's me and who's
the other one uh Olivia and Olivia is
Olivia I'm thinking about because the
shoes I thought were so cool and the
fact that I found them at Goodwill I
thought was so cool but they were 20
bucks so I'm wondering if maybe I should
fix them so that I have more of an edge
when people are voted I mean Ian was the
highest of the first round and he won
easily I don't think the audience is uh
honoring our request all right if the
shoes aren't a huge thing I'll we can
it's fine it's dick to your vision
you're still under the 50 Max that we've
said all right but so I'm kind of
confused about this because there's so
yes there's a surprise in the outfit
that I want you to reveal when you
de-shed you're late when you shed your
legs I got you I got it yeah gotcha um
do you have a name for this outfit yeah
um this is hot at brunch hot at run yeah
I think this could this could really be
comfortable outfit but also you look
super sick you could you could walk
around look awesome okay and you could
also yeah
and some orange juice maybe Mimosa right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
come on that goes without saying I guess
yeah okay so hot at brunch and this one
clocks in at 47.95 so it is right it is
the priciest outfit but as Olivia said
that is almost entirely due to the shoes
which were twenty dollars how much was
this um sweater
the sweater
6.99 6.99 no it was the first thing I I
picked up really cool it is cool
so you uh you built it around that huh I
did I did okay why are people saying hi
viscore
I don't know
oh the pants fit me that's so dub okay
okay let's go yeah we got some Spicy
Cool chicks you actually
your whole outfit thank you you spent a
lot you spent a lot but you got a lot
thank you
there's the shoes tops all right here I
come pants long sleeves and glasses all
right here we go
all right
that's awesome
yeah that that dude looks like he eats
brunch can you see yeah this one that's
your brunch
throw the shoes
so that guy goes to air wand dude that
guy spends 25 on a [__] Shake right
there I can see this being like a Gucci
outfit to be honest
I mean
looks good so do you want to show the
surprise yeah there's some sort of
second layer to this it's a little hot
yeah yeah what's the situation yeah
brunch okay so I'm wearing this at
brunch this off when it gets a little
warm yeah it's August it's August brunch
yeah and it's like getting to be about
11 it's heating up it's heating up
wait pull her down [__]
[Laughter]
oh yeah representing my favorite
Broadway show yes wow the energy change
a lot wow it's hot
wow come on you are looking hot at
brunch right now I'll have the eggs
benedict please
extra hard can I get the Benedict extra
hard I don't like the runny White
no hollandaise it's the orange juice
freshers 86 the hollandaise oh it's
canned no I don't want it then
[Laughter]
I'll have one Pellegrino please
uh are we having mimosas today yeah
wow
very good very good well done Olivia
brunch all right uh mine is last
and uh I gotta say so my theme is
it's it's Sam's cousin uh not actually
Stan's cousin but Sam's outfit's cousin
uh she did the Florida man
um
just to go along with that theme
actually I think an appropriate name for
mine is Ohio man
um this is the Ohio man outfit and I
spent what is it a hazmat suit uh I got
him
um spent uh 26.95 so pretty close to
that 25 amount that you said
you have a lot of [__] here yeah I also
managed to get a lot of [__] as he said
uh a hat for five bucks an accessory
which will be I don't want to reveal yet
for three bucks a shirt uh and a long
sleeve and shorts
um all for 26.95 that is
some impressive shopping thank you thank
you
um
why is his tape so strong
why is that the booth is like shaking
right now
got air a lot of violence going on in
there so do you want the the outer layer
buttoned up or open open for sure open
got it so shirt and then open outer
layer and then the rest should all be uh
you got it self-evident there
I'm sorry Dan I was speaking this is
called Ohio man Ohio man yeah very much
Ohio man we got Florida man and Ohio man
like I said cousins
but distinct uh breeds unto themselves
so
Ohioans and chat rise up yes yeah you
you're definitely not going to be
offended
what's that how did you get all this for
24 bucks
uh I mean it was all it was all like six
bucks five bucks bro these you
the advances do not even get close to
fitting okay I was a little worried
about that they were the biggest ones we
could find I think they're just XL not
double XL now these these are like small
size I mean it shrunk considerably
whatever it was this is crazy I can't
even get the zipper up
I'm trying to tuck in the shirts my junk
doesn't come out okay yeah we appreciate
that
Chad's saying you should wear one of
these outfits home to ELA
Riser I'm I can't wait to get out of it
just feels so dirty
I promise you they clean them actually I
don't I can't actually yeah I mean I
believe them I believe the Goodwill it's
kind of insane they're all from
different stores but all smell the same
that is that that is something different
because it's like well it's what all
this old [__] together just creates a oh
they probably it's you know what it is
it's industrial detergent here we go
hell yeah
looks like oh that bag is not a part of
it
I think that was just in that other bag
yeah you can lose it oh yeah that's a
Teddy fresh bag
Babylon Rising I was like this is a nice
bag
first shall be the last what this looks
like I've got like a straight up like
something weird
[Laughter]
so yeah the shirt appears to be from the
the shirt appears to be from uh like a
car dealership yes I figure you you work
at a car dealership
um you want the the Hat of course was
what the outfit was built around I found
that hat and said you know what
the Matrix my brothers
uh
yeah uh
yeah
[Music]
hold it up
sure yeah so they had lots of uh kind of
conspiracy core literature in the book
section as well so I figured after
researching the historical connection
between the occult secret societies and
biblical prophecies with intensity for
five years I must say there's hardly a
need to study any further
Babylon Rising
big Illuminati yeah Babylon that we rise
upon my brothers hell yeah
so yeah yeah people are saying I nailed
the Ohio course so thank you yeah I uh
I'm glad I did yourself Hey Brother
let's go on get a bite at the diner oh
we can't go to that one it's with too
near us school we got to go to the one
on the other side of town
all right and I'll say that I believe
there is a pedophile coat running the
government
oh hold on
oh he said it people hold on I gotta
drive around this here's school a lot of
them can't be within a hundred yards as
I was saying there's a pedophile coat
running this damn country
well for sure I would be part of it if I
was in there boy let me tell you what
okay fun
thank you all right so that's it um that
is round two so I'm gonna throw up the
poll uh uh did you send me the second
round yet you did yeah you're so good
Kim all right here we go a little
reminder of all the looks
here's so gross we got Florida man with
the NRA that's such a good find Sam the
[__] NRA bag uh EK by CG a hot at
brunch and Ohio man
so here we go I'm gonna throw up the
pool right now
and there we go get your votes in people
thank you
all right early ooh we have a very close
uh race between Florida man and hot at
brunch
they're tied at 40 each
those are both blowing out the other two
cam you and I we're getting blown out
right now that's fine ladies
39.39 it's perfectly uh
perfectly balanced here I come as
confident [__] [__] show me bro
confident hot sexy
famous
who wants some it's Ethan
uh I can't believe how close this is Sam
and Olivia are like tied Ken that's so
badass how you put that together so fast
I'm waiting for the second one get the
final round they're they're still tied
hot at brunch
cause you got the outfit change almost
it's pretty and then Florida man
so where's the pool pretty special I
mean the the fact it was an NRA bag when
it when it's Ethan obviously the lore
makes that pretty powerful I took that L
right when I saw that yeah but also you
haven't taken the mail yet Hamilton too
you're actually in the lead right now
you've pulled ahead by one percentage
point
yeah it's 38.39 right now
I'm gonna vote the thing is that I think
is worth considering is the pr the spend
difference there is a pretty mess our
audience does not see they don't care
they don't give a [__] and I I don't
blame it and it's okay it's fine it's
okay but it is worth because we would
need to intervene if we wanted to have a
meaningful penalty yeah right yeah but
we're not going to do that
uh they're back to 39 30. holy [__] 39
30 that's holding steady
that is insane maybe we should do our
Revo
so everyone can vote oh that's a good
idea love suggesting we end it and then
just put up just between the two of them
love it okay so let's do that right now
well good job everybody round
2.1 I'm pretty sure I just got ringworm
and Sam Olivia we're still friends no
matter what Sam Olivia and just rhyme
people so real quick big uh said yeah I
wanted to debate a gen Z woman not Ethan
yeah I guess I don't want to put that on
you but he's just such a coward you're
moving the goal post I'm a feminist what
do you want
you think I'll make you look dumb it was
hot at brunch by the way right that was
hot at brunch he said I'm okay I'm ready
to call into a podcast with feminists
what so how many gen Z women are there
dying to get you on their podcast big
Nick stop it you're moving the goal post
you're being a coward
just [__] Chris Lynn if you believe
the [__] you're saying call in mm-hmm
all right so here we go round 2.1
and wait can there be three options no
just two Oh I thought you just put the
final three up against each other that's
fine no no I'm trying to filter out this
round too I got you I got you we're
doing ranked ranked Choice voting here I
got you and with the ranked choice
you know maybe maybe uh Florida man's
cousins the original Ohio man voters
have uh broken strongly for right their
family members in Florida
uh very close but Sam now has a slight
Edge
oh it's shrinking
yeah I mean it's
it's blue that is really close that is
really really close see if the Gap
closes at all when it uh when it updates
a few times here
so we've got uh 52 Florida man 48 hot at
brunch even with the outfit switch there
you know Florida man just hit hard with
that NRA bag yeah it is it is very
powerful we've gained about a thousand
votes and the percentages have held
steady
um starting to think that Florida man
might have this
yeah I'm just starting to think that I
think it's and it very oh oh it dropped
down once but then went back up
immediately I think we can call it guys
unfortunately Olivia I'll be honest
I thought you were gonna win I thought
yours was exceptionally good and Sam hit
us with that NRA bag though which I
think took it down same with Ian he got
that dad husband feminist shirt like how
where do you even get that stuff you
know Olivia the Hamilton shirt was
amazing thank you I love that Thank You
Hamilton dude I did make the Fringe
myself this morning you did that just
because I'm able to
it's free
it's free did you cut it was it did you
I did cut it
hmm it's still a tiny shirt it would
have been a crop top I just wanted
something special interesting okay okay
okay I mean it's still lost so there you
go all right so we do have the final
round of voting here between Hollywood
night and Florida man here we go I don't
want the smoke with Sam oh you want the
smoke oh no there's gonna be an argument
tonight you know pairing this family
apart I don't want to mess up he's by
myself don't try and don't try and throw
it to her listen kovid that outfit is
just it so hits all the notes you got
the conspiracy the coveted shirt is so
powerful too imagine walking around the
na NRA duffel bag like how [__] crazy
is your life I mean
it's probably pretty normal and yeah a
lot of places and your life is [__]
crazy where nobody in your life is like
what is wrong with you
Hollywood nights that one actually
looked good and it just had a certain
vibe to it yep uh well
it is once again pretty close but I have
to say Florida man seems to be taking
the wow give it us give it some time
it's at four thousand yeah yeah well
let's let's get for like seven thousand
more okay very close let it cook let it
cook uh Hollywood Nights is at 46
percent
Florida man's at 54 it's very close vote
here
now how are you guys feeling Sam and Ian
are you I think
the winner should get to keep their
clothes so Sam you could you should get
to keep the bag I think I'm not okay
holding on to any of this [__] I think
it'd be a good look I think you all can
have the clothes send it home with me I
got it you want to keep that just return
it to Goodwill
it's a pretty nice jacket
just return it all don't ask for a
refund no I don't want to refund you
just bring it all back I would just dump
it back in yeah put it in the donation
just bring it all back where it came all
right we're almost at 8 000 and Sam is
still comfortably in the lead here I
think we can call this
wow congratulations
[Applause]
Florida man thank you thank you 20 the
proud winner of a 20 Sharkey's gift card
yes what will you be ordering Sam
the quesadilla
my favorite
quesadilla I'll split it with Ian
um
you're you're a winner a graceful winner
offering to split her quesadilla Ian a
bitter loser loser
and you win all these you know have some
braids yeah chill no I said I said as
much much deserved win
that's what I like it's very sweet
humble and defeat
well should we order Sharkies
oh I haven't had Sharkies in years I
never had it I like everything down to
that it's pretty good obviously I like
it everyone's saying but Sam I hope you
all know right now I'm just kidding yeah
I got you let's get some Sharky's yeah
they're salsa I just called salsa dip
where what is wrong with me bro is that
Florida man you got that dip really the
Florida man them Mexican's got some good
dip stupid
love that Mexican dip
let's do it because I don't I can't be
here very long so let's get that order
in all right working on it
everybody send me what you want
congratulations you guys that was very
well you all did great
did any of the outfits have an effect on
you you're like maybe I might maybe they
did I would say the first two Zach and
Ian's I felt like oh wow this is kind of
interesting this is an interesting look
I think can someone
put the Ethan bust to the corresponding
outfit
like the I want to see Zach's bust on
that outfit that's a really really
really really really good idea
so uh as we put together this Sharky's
order in honor of Sam
we still have some other stories to get
to let me type to you what I want
I want a chicken one of them chicken
burritos with extra sauce
them Mexicans making really good sauce
and them crunchy things those crunchy
triangles that's pretty good too
mm-hmm
they got these silly looking kinda half
of a hamburger you gotta eat it from the
side that's pretty tasty but I don't get
how to eat it
it's the Sharky's burrito
is it with Citrus chicken natural
chicken
natural there's two this is Citrus I'll
take Citrus chicken [__] fried
chicken with [__] Fried Chicken
Citrus chicken and then the Sharky
Salsas everything to me so extra salty
Sharky salsa
got it light rice
[Music]
okay
that Zach how do you do that Rice gum
you want black beans or pinto beans I'm
gonna be doing we're mixing I'm gonna be
doing Pinto this evening
excellent choice I like them brown ones
[Music]
um
but the color of cornbread
mm-hmm
what do you call that Mexican dip the
red stuff with the tomatoes in it
dip is dip Mexico dip I like to call it
I don't know what it's called and the
jalapenos oh we those hot jalapenos
tasty though
I'll tell you what man those Mexicans
sure can Mexican cook
[Music]
mmm
yes sir and them rice they cook
it's all red
we got carrots and peas uh-huh
I love me some Mexican dip
yes sir
and they got that pork there to I don't
know how they make that pork mate
[Music]
well then I muted I just saw something
when I went to the restroom just now
that I think we might have to uh try
look at this
bunless a bunless sandwich it's almost
keto friendly Dan I thought you were
talking about the clogged toilet
it probably looks like this it's a
bunless double damage yeah
for four weeks only oh we gotta try that
dude I'm in you know how it is
[__] oh boy
ow oh God
are you okay
okay everyone get your orders in let's
we'll move on can you give me a Sharky
Sharky's an estimate Sam because it was
gonna like take an hour I can't uh it's
gonna take 45 minutes to an hour
[__] that's too long
dude don't do this oh boy oh boy someone
want to go get it it's Sharkies can
someone get it that'd be it would
honestly it would probably be the same
amount of time honestly where it is
really there's not one closer no uh
maybe maybe we'll just order a different
place or just it's not rain check the
whole idea is shark Keys though let's do
Sharky's on Friday okay we can do
Sharky's on Friday okay all right sounds
good
wait so we're not going to do the KFC on
Friday
we can do it on Monday with Eddie okay
there we go there we go
eat it he's on his uh troops
no he just got a drink before I think
yeah drink oh oh okay
you just gotta remind him he gotta drink
what I will put in the blender I don't
know no it seems like he has some kind
of special drink that makes him have
diarrhea or something
yeah it was like I mean I was like
talking about like Herbalife stuff yeah
he does have a special drink he's on
here please
describing it
is he in the Herbalife I think it's
I can ask him on Monday with peace and
love listen Eddie is the ultimate
Hollywood extra
okay like he personifies the Trope of
the the guy who's an extra and
everything in Hollywood perfectly in
every way and part of that is being
involved in some sort of pyramid scammer
and others wait he would say if it's not
a pyramid scheme it's not appearance
it's multi-level marketing right yeah
don't be spreading lies on the good
people of Herbalife right yeah yeah
maybe we should talk to him about that I
just need a picture of his garage I need
to see if he has like cases of Herbalife
in there you want me to text him tell
him I want to see if he can take a
picture of the amount of Herbalife he
has in his house that he's trying to
sell oh that's a good idea okay okay
because that's then we'll know how deep
in he is you know okay I'm texting him
now oh here it is the feel great system
thank you
a little homework for Eddie for Friday
or Monday I mean
this is uh from Olivia thank you
yerba mate people are saying 10 minutes
before a meal
all right let's try this again here
I'm drinking my una mate this is the
unimate balance 10 minutes before a meal
cheers it tastes good
prices Eddie specifically says he
doesn't sell he only buys he's a fan of
their product right okay well I mean
that's so funny
yeah you think so he was he was
shielding something last episode though
he was talking about a link
I'd like to know what it is it's really
delicious this is the balance that I
mixed in water it's in cold water
yeah it's yerba mate it's a tea okay
have you guys ever had it no I don't
know bomb I love it but what is it
supposed to do for you
I I don't know I know it has a lot of
I'm pretty positive it has a lot of
caffeine in it it makes me very shaky
well just drink it looks like your
[__] pesto [__]
oh I know I hate that kind of tea where
it's like
I see you pull it out it's like a
hardcore tea yeah
I mean just drinking a glass of water
before you eat is going to make you less
hungry
fill you up more
but um let's see if he tries to sell out
something because it coats my stomach
and then digests the food resistant
foreign
this is Eddie before eating like 20
pound cakes
from the uh Bob's Big Boy
this is my special I can't I'm I'm with
love of course Teddy we love it and it's
before a meal and I won't gain weight
right I mean it works let's tell him to
bring some in let's try it on Monday
he's lost 30 pounds yeah he looks
amazing he didn't try to sell it to us
either so I think he really just loves
the product yeah he said the link is in
his bio he did if you if you click on
that if you click on the link no over
here that he has this
great
you're about to go to a link I can't see
the yeah if you open that unit City okay
so he's got a he does have a affiliate
link yes an affiliate link okay yeah oh
yeah
all righty
so what do we got here time based eating
often referred to as intermediate
fasting what do we talk about
intermediate fasting I thought this was
like a beverage
okay so let's see five
when why uh it starts at 5 p.m starts at
five
okay so I guess your first meal is at
five to seven pm
well of course you're gonna lose weight
you're not eating how's the beverage
taking credit for this
some people just benefit from the
structure of the system you know
they found a way to sell you an
intermittent fasting diet what's the
catch though so here it is five to seven
drink your drink have dinner
8 PM fasting starts
midnight blood sugar normalizes
the [__] did you eat
seven hours for your blood sugar to
normalize
insulin levels drop 2 A.M but you don't
control this
you're not in charge of the biology of
the body
4am gluccon
glucacon glucacon
glucacon is released
6 a.m digestive system resets
seven to nine a.m we drink some [__] the
ultimate unimate
8 A.M fat burning begins baby
HGH increases
10 a.m body ramps up for that fat
burning oh at noon we do get to eat
lunch
so you're having two meals a day here
and that's the end we didn't go a full
24 hour cycle what do we do afternoon I
think it's well then you wait till five
to seven for dinner but there's no like
biology happening in that I mean we did
we need every step of the way what's
where is it going well so during the
feeding window your metabolism stops
it's all bad
um
death
okay it's working for him
he died
what'd the experts say Dr Aaron Glenn
she looks like
an expert
this woman is not a doctor look at her
that haircut doesn't say doctor to me
free Joe Exotic that haircut says chain
smoker
in Las Vegas slots
wear the coin
can you Google her name is she real
let's see
Dr Colleen oh well she is she looks
lovely wait she looks tobacco-free
oh [__] I don't want to show her dress
but let's see if he's a real person
oh dude wait hold on hold on
I'll buy the pool
stop get off of this
as an obesity specialist I'm always
looking for ways to help my patients
feel like they weren't dieting but that
really works on Fat Loss great feel
great is the answer I can honestly say
this is by far the most successful myth
that I've found in my 30 years of
practice
thank you Dr Colleen Andrus
sir Dr Aaron says I drink unumate and
place a coffee as my morning source of
caffeine it gives me an energy boost
helps me focus and help support my mood
I'm just such a [__] without my una
mate
I am such a catty [__] without my
unimate but first unimate combine these
benefits with the cholesterol support
and healthy glucose response to meals I
get from balance okay yeah so there it
is uh it works for real doctors real
people whoops don't show that thank you
let's see what Eddie's up to if you have
his most recent 41 minutes ago
if you have a problem with me oh that's
it
why did he just say that
then what I want to know the next part
there it is Eddie he's crushing it
wow that's about a round of applause uh
well if uh una mate if you're looking
for a good old beverage use his link for
Christ's sake
don't look into it do your research
hey guys love y'all so much my
birthday's on Friday but I sadly don't
think I
don't blah blah do you think I get a
birthday shout out it would mean the
world to me story
happy birthday to you
we love you for that
[Music]
hey
I'm about to read you a story of a girl
who had a great life and a happy
birthday
that's right
what is this story
this is story art all right kill it
Julie Joe said he's losing weight
because he isn't taking in as many
calories not because those products do
anything hey how dare you calling the
question una made we don't know that
Julie we don't know that what do you
what are your credentials
Chrissy Sherlock's back you're a gee
Chrissy's a Jee thank you Chrissy so I
guess it's been three hours I do like to
get home in time to spend time with the
kiddos
more time with the kiddos this ah God
but the Vitali one is so good
we could save it for Friday though
and it's been three hours it's been
three hours wow
having too much fun over here
this is the one that may put me down the
Vitality
um Wormhole I'll just show you guys this
one yeah so Vitali is one of the old
school prankers
total piece of [__] recently was
arrested for tripping acid and beating
the [__] out of a random woman
yeah he was the target of one of my
favorite videos feeding the homeless
where he was screaming at them to get
the [__] away from him oh and they got
sandwiches
he's playing this inspirational music
but he's screaming at them
to back the [__] up
anyway he's back he yeah he beat the
[__] of a woman I don't know how he
didn't go to jail or get deported but he
I guess he just paid her off and made it
go away
here he is he's back on Tick Tock let's
take a look
I can show you I'm sorry I'm stuck it's
still good I can repay you no no no
I mean the question is always is it real
no but I do have to say
she puts in more I put her heart and
soul into that that's that's the only
thing that kind of tips it for me
is that she's really on her [__] if
she's an actor actress actor
that that's my read on it that it is
fake but she's doing a hell of a job
selling it but there's nothing funnier
than going and sucking the wigs off of
black women
[Music]
[Applause]
[__] a smoker I'm sorry
wow what do you guys think is it real
she's really putting her heart into it
she's good
I can show you I'm sorry I'm stuck it's
still good I'm supposed to get I can
repay you is there a way for him to know
that it would come off by sucking it or
because sometimes they're braided in and
yeah no that's why that's what makes me
figure
yeah yeah I don't think it's real
she did a good job acting she really
slayed that what's interesting is you go
uh to his Tick Tock the tally is King
it's him breaking black people
he's bringing back uh pranks in the hood
he actually even calls it that
wait he really on his YouTube channel
he's uploading the full version and it's
all pranks in the Hood wow give me his
YouTube channel 25 is this official back
uh
uh I think a follow for the wildest
videos on talk talk yeah this is this is
official
this has 10 million views
I'm sorry oh this isn't a prank it's a
crime
if this wasn't acting this is legit
assault
that's the because yeah this has to be
fake
because this man is on thin ice he's
about to be deported like if he farts on
a cop he'll be deported
he's Russian by the way he came in for
school or something and then
came here for the Bangbus yeah he
famously was on the Bang Bus once and he
was flaccid he couldn't get it up
Jesus he he and his body did Bangbus
and his buddy ends up able to perform
and he's just in the back
jerking off trying to get hard the whole
time he's just flattened the whole time
it's very very very very embarrassing
video yeah goddamn wow
[Music]
here it is here's his channel let's see
what look at this thumbnail dude are you
[__] kidding me dude
blow it upload it two days ago yeah this
is like oh he's active all right
are you oh he's this one guy he's
getting oh no this is three years ago so
this is his big comeback video
oh oh
pranks in the hood then
I swear I saw him doing that those were
the names of some of the tick tocks like
in the Hood
um oh so here yeah you can see
uh blowing girls wigs off
prank
um
here is fighting in the hood prank yeah
yeah here it is
fighting in the hood prank you guys
egging cars in the hood
I also think the main source of his
income
um I don't know if he's still up and
running but it looks current is he has a
website that's called Vitaly uncensored
ain't nobody's paying for that right um
and it's basically just like pranks with
nudity some type of porn star it's just
it's so remove it just feels like a
relic of like the early 2000s he's not
moving on it doesn't not even like
you know the last decade but like two
decades ago like girls gone wild energy
you know but some of these are hitting
for him again this one has 3.4 million
oh is this your car I had your car I'm
sorry
some white dude just egg my car [__]
get
she seems like she's she's like who
she's such an incredible actor
but it's got to be fake what are you
doing no no no
did you egg my car bro she's I really
hope it's fake him is genuine
this is you want some Tomatoes
but she's so good and
I mean you would think because I thought
why would you egg my car I had her car
bite me bite me why would I fight you
fight me this looks like an older video
[Music]
right now no no no what are you guys
doing hey Kyle come on hey come over
here come right here come over here
I'm not doing anything
Tomatoes clean it off all right clean it
off you don't want no issues clean it
off unless you want to fight me can I
give you a massage you want to bite me
in the car man
oh so it's just it's a magnet
it's just a magnet Dan
you get it
[Applause]
that's why
I think this was real I think I'm sorry
to tell you guys I think he really did
this They're laughing because it's not
real tomato because it was a magnet well
and then the guard was like that's why
there had a camera there
clean it off unless you want to fight me
can I give you a massage you want to
bite me yeah man between the car man
thank God that Emoji's there to let me
know please laugh
please laugh
the fact okay you know what because I
was starting to think this felt pretty
real wow the fact that she starts
laughing yeah okay you know what it's
fake I think yeah
but nobody would react that way well you
got me so good let me give you a hug
like no that's not that's not happening
it's such a quick that gives it away
she was breaking character and started
giggling she's straight up like needs an
Oscar though maybe maybe
because I feel like the reveal totally
kills the illusion
[__]
here's another one classic Vitali
and the Pud egging cars in the hood
we like to prank them black folks they
got the funniest reactions
that's why I write in the hood
sometimes
dude my stove broke my stove broke bro
I'm sorry dude your car your car your
car is nice bro your car is very nice
dude what are you doing
this one's fake as [__]
he's like yeah
you need to park better all right I
encourage everybody to go do pranks in
the hood
go make your own content in the hood
pranking people
it's a movement we call it pranks in the
hood because I just egged your car
right here you look at your parking job
bro
how does he know which is his car
how did you know the whole scenario just
doesn't make any sense
so what dude you don't even Park like
this I'm sorry would you take my car
like
though because it looks cute but look at
all this parking over here why the [__]
did you egg my car I don't know what are
you gonna do about it I'm sorry dude
with shaving cream how are you gonna egg
me with it what if I egg you are you
serious dude yeah
that's so dumb fake Lane
here let's see let's watch the whole bed
and see
oh
Ethan I thought you had to go I'm just I
can't I gotta watch this now I'm in the
the vortex
I'll leave in 10 minutes
10 minutes is good
it's all black women by the way which is
like even if they're
consenting it's like in the totality of
it it's so [__]
weird
hello hello
is this dude dressed as Captain Sparrow
what's going on back here
dude's got a pirate hat on
the music is like this is just fun
loving pranks on black people
where I assault you
I love how her hair is styled under the
wig
you'd think that if she was going out
with a wig
yeah well her hair just looks like that
you think she needs to style it to make
it up like that it's pretty I don't know
maybe the way the wig was laying on it
but it seems like if you were having a
wig you would want it more flat
right that's true the hurricane ain't no
hurricane okay
big nose that's all you have against me
you're beautiful sorry let's see if
there's a let's see the next one
this man is just straight up harassing
black people
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm sorry
this video is so [__] even though it's
like probably all fake
here's one you all should check out epic
farting in the hood prank
I loved it like this [__] still exists
it's so wild bro epic farting in the
hood prank why are you farting people in
the hood
I'm pretty sure everybody doesn't like
being farted on
you could do it
farting on people in the suburb prank
what's the what's the context here
what's the subtext
if this was real they'd be calling the
police right I mean uh
and or he'd be getting his ass beat
excuse me
let's try one more
it was the best reaction ever I'm so
sorry oh let me see her reveal that that
really gives it away
reading a prank and I know what I did to
you
500 here that's for you oh my god
dangerous game was the best reaction
ever he's a terrible actor right I mean
that's [__]
so sorry
excuse me
is wrong with you yeah this shit's fake
it's all fake yeah which is good but
it's super racist that make it seem like
everybody in the prank is just so
dangerous
and crazy
it's just a really weird thing to put
out there
so weird also reinforces like harmful
stereotypes
from a fake video
Italy's back y'all
mm-hmm
he's back
that's right
yes sir
um
our boy Vitaly is back
yes Ryan
all right guys that's it for me
um
you know thank you for being here
enjoying the lovely Wednesday oh
Tomorrow there's no leftovers because
Hassan is it betrayed me and went to
Japan even though yeah why is that
betrayal of you I because he should have
been here oh I thought I canceled last
week so it was funny I thought uh you
were saying you should uh should have
invited you I don't have time for that
let's [__] go to Japan dude anywhere
fun
if we can work I guess maybe
of course we can work
it does look really fun though take us
to Japan
just just trying to get a vacation out
of Ethan I don't know just
well the last time we did a family
vacation to Vegas that was fun that was
really fun how long ago let's go to the
Vegas
Dubai it was a year ago Dubai let's all
go let's hit up it was in March Dubai
hopefully they probably confiscate my
passport because I'm Jew or Eva Israeli
stamp on it uh UAE and Israel get along
these days I believe because they're
kind of in the Saudi Arabia accident no
Jews no gays I know the rules I don't
think that's the case anyway
um
they do let them in Japan though just
say
the gays are allowed in Japan
uh yeah I was talking about the twos but
yeah the gays are alive too yeah all
white people are the same in Japan they
don't distinguish Jew from anything else
um tomorrow is Thursday there's no
episode we'll be back on Friday for a
after dark Extravaganza as always and
um
that's what it is y'all so thank you
thank you
thank you to Glass CB thank you for
reacting to my music guys should we
watch one more glassy bee did did you
check any of those maybe yeah he said
that all of them were copyright free I
checked three of them they all were okay
all right let's close it out with some
glassyb
so take us out to play us out to take us
out to play us out what does that mean
what does that mean to play us out [__]
it
I love that it's like a totally normal
[__] it's like I still don't
understand why he didn't get it okay so
let me sort by popular let's see glassyb
he's Sky skating skrilla starkilla
Brantley versus keemstar boom boom remix
okay I love this one let's go live from
Buffalo oh we see okay I've seen this
one you're watching the Kingston show
with your home
classy B
[Music]
isser
just feel the beat disagree this one's
for the boys no girls tonight this one's
for the boys
I disagree Brantley
on the H3 podcast a guy got fired his
name is Abe stock yes
[Music]
you can just go full screen and then end
it after uh after it's done
recently he's got into a controversy
because he tried to get somebody fired
uh a security guard
s
[Music]
loser
you're not supposed to do that
you're a loser
Brantley you have a mental disability
known as gen Z